bonjour à toutes et à tous merci d'être
présent aujourd'hui sur la chaîne
Youtube de France 3 Bourgogne
Franche-Comté pour notre émission et
nous les jeunes on est au CDI du lycée
Anna Judic à Semur-en-Auxois avec plein
de lycéens
on a un petit bug technique alors on va
régler ça
va reprendre je pense pas de problème
c'est tout bon ah excusez-nous pour le
petit bug technique on revient donc je
disais on est avec plein de lycéens des
premières déterminales déjà comment vous
allez
on voit qu'ils sont ouais très motivés
en tout cas et je suis aussi avec
Nicolas salut Nicolas comment tu vas
salut mazire ça va et toi bah écoute ça
va petit retour au lycée c'est un peu un
peu spécial
un peu ce dont on va parler aujourd'hui
oui on va parler des on va débattre sur
de nombreux sujets des sujets que les
lycéens ici ont tous choisis on leur a
rien imposé donc on va parler de
politique d'écologie des réseaux sociaux
et enfin plein de sujets que vous
découvrirez en regardant l'émission
justement il y a beaucoup de sujets
effectivement alors on n'est pas seul à
mener ce débat puisqu'on est aussi avec
Aubery aubury qui est juste là-bas salut
Bury est-ce que tu peux nous dire un
petit peu c'est quoi ton rôle du coup
personne qui sont là pour vous regarder
vous les lycéens débattre donc ils vont
avoir des questions certainement donc
moi je suis là pour vous les faire
parvenir et puis comme ça vous pourrez
en discuter avec eux d'ailleurs ils
étaient un peu impatients ils
attendaient longtemps depuis que ça
commence donc maintenant il est temps
que on se lance ah bah oui lançons-nous
ça y est donc posez vos questions on y
répondra et je propose qu'on démarre
tout de suite par le premier thème pour
ça avec Nicolas on s'est rendu dans
plusieurs établissements notamment à
Dijon on a parlé à plusieurs lycéens et
on leur a demandé ce qu'il craignait
pour leur avenir et tous nous ont parlé
de quelque chose de commun oui le
système scolaire bah d'ailleurs c'est
notre premier sujet donc ben je propose
qu'on s'assoit et puis qu'on commence le
débat et qu'on laisse parler déjà allez
c'est parti
alors le système scolaire c'est un sujet
très clivant surtout auprès auprès des
jeunes ils ont beaucoup de choses à dire
des choses qui n'ont pas forcément
toujours très positive toi Rachel
concrètement c'est quoi ton point de vue
là-dessus est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
qui te dérange ou pas je pense que pour
commencer déjà c'est le la question de
l'emploi du temps et des programmes
scolaires qui sont plus vraiment adaptés
pour nous pour nous aider à nous
développer tout au long du parcours
qu'on mène d'accord et quelqu'un d'autre
à quelque chose à ajouter tu voulais
ajouter quelque chose effectivement les
journées sont trop longues et puis s'il
y avait que ça ça irait peut-être mieux
mais il y a aussi énormément de devoirs
qu'on nous fait faire à la maison et qui
donc nous prennent un temps libre énorme
et ça nous laisse pas le temps de se
consacrer à nos occupations nos passions
même notre famille ou quoi donc c'est un
peu dommage
je trouve également que dans notre
système scolaire actuel on sous-estime
beaucoup la question de la santé mentale
qui comment dire
alors ce sujet là on va y revenir
peut-être juste après on va d'abord
finir sur le système scolaire
c'est beaucoup mis de côté c'est
c'est vrai tout à fait d'ailleurs en
2022 selon un sondage il y a un Français
sur deux qui trouve que le système
scolaire est sur le déclin n'est plus
efficace est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette stat est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'aujourd'hui le système scolaire ne
marche plus vraiment et qui n'est plus
adapté à ce que vous vous demandez
je trouve que le système scolaire en ce
moment c'est souvent quelque chose qu'on
parle beaucoup même nous entre jeunes et
oui ça va être principalement le sujet
des heures on trouve qu'on fait beaucoup
trop d'heures on nous demande d'avoir
quelque chose comme 9h de sommeil ce qui
est recommandé pour un adolescent de
notre âge et on va commencer les cours à
vers 7 heures 7 heures ça dépend des
lycées des collèges tout ça
et va falloir se lever plus tôt par
exemple la plupart ici vont se lever
vers 6h du matin chez eux le temps de
prendre le bus tout ça et quand ils vont
rentrer le soir ils arrivent vers 18h
chez eux voir
19h la plupart et de 19h pour avoir un
petit peu de temps de repos on a même
pas une heure ensuite faut aller faut
faire les devoirs une heure de te voir
faut manger faut se laver et ensuite on
doit aller se doucher enfin on doit se
doucher on doit aller dormir et ça
allait 9 heures de sommeil sont très
difficiles à avoir avec un emploi du
temps aussi conséquent pour pour des
personnes de notre âge quoi
est-ce que quelqu'un va ajouter quelque
chose
et ce que je trouve dommage aussi dans
le système scolaire actuel c'est que on
a beaucoup de cours différents on nous
demande d'avoir des bonnes notes dans
toutes les matières différentes c'est à
dire que ça va être compliqué pour
beaucoup d'élèves d'avoir des bonnes
notes à la fois dans les matières
littérales dans les matières qui vont
être plus scientifiques d'autant plus
qu'on a pas énormément de matière
artistiques pour les gens qui préfèrent
ça alors certes dans ce lycée là on a
une option et une spécialité théâtre ce
qui est vraiment bien pour le coup mais
il y a pas vraiment de spiritualité arts
plastiques par exemple ou quoi et je
trouve ça dommage que ce soit pas plus
généralisé pour aller vraiment dans des
lycée spécialisés si on veut faire de
l'art alors que c'est un domaine comme
de un autre et si on pouvait s'entraîner
sur de l'art par exemple la musique etc
c'est un travail que beaucoup veulent
faire aujourd'hui et ça permettrait
aussi de savoir mieux comment
s'organiser
il y a plein d'autres trucs ce serait
vraiment nain
quelqu'un d'autre pour revenir sur ce
que dit Achille il a raison parce que on
nous demande tant de choses sauf qu'on
connaît quasiment peu de d'éléments pour
lesquels on pourrait s'intéresser on
nous parle d'histoire de Français qui
sont certes intéressants pour certains
mais d'autres ne trouveront pas ça pour
eux ce qu'ils aiment vraiment et on n'a
pas de d'heures ou des d'éléments qui
pourraient nous aider à trouver des
activités qui pourraient nous plaire et
même pour un potentialité d'avenir de
métier etc on a rien qui nous met qui
nous mène sur cette une voie comme ça
savoir qu'est-ce qui pourrait nous
plaire réellement
on va souvent comparer le système
scolaire français à d'autres pays donc
principalement ce qu'on entend beaucoup
ça va être l'Allemagne qui propose un
système scolaire qu'à partir du collège
si je dis pas de bêtises les élèves vont
avoir tout l'après-midi de libre pour
pouvoir s'intéresser à des options type
du sport des métiers ou alors travailler
en amont pour gagner de l'argent et ça
leur permettra de découvrir peut-être
plus tard le métier qui veulent faire en
faisant des stages ou des choses comme
ça ou en France on n'a pas le temps
parce que comme on l'a déjà dit
plusieurs fois notre emploi du temps est
trop serré il y a aussi en Finlande on
dit que c'est l'un des meilleurs
systèmes scolaires mondial ils font 8h30
15h30 ça leur permet d'avoir une grosse
partie de l'après-midi de libre et il y
a beaucoup de système scolaires et où
ils sont comme ça mais justement en
France nous on n'a pas de temps de libre
où on pourrait s'intéresser à nos
passions des choses comme ça alors je
crois qu'il y a Laurane qui veut parler
qu'est-ce que tu veux nous dire dessus
justement je voulais juste te dire que
je trouve qu'en France on apprend en
termes d'éducation on a des matières
trop peu concrètes on n'apprend pas
assez des choses qui nous seront utiles
plus tard dans la vie comme par exemple
je sais pas moi se débrouiller avec tes
comptes avec ce qu'il faut payer ou avec
les papiers en général en fait tout par
exemple
donc vous pensez que le système scolaire
actuel ne vous prépare pas à la virée
bien ça c'est ça Rachel c'est ça par
exemple en Estonie il y a des cours de
cuisine ou de bricolage qui sont qui
sont intégrés au programme scolaire et
ce qui permet aux élèves de d'apprendre
des bases plutôt générale pour qu'il
leur serviront concrètement pour
l'avenir après
quelqu'un d'accord quelqu'un oui
je trouve qu'il y a trop de matière qui
sont trop générales et il y a trop de
matière en général enfin dans la section
générale qui nous serviront pas
forcément plus tard et justement les
matières par exemple les bacs
professionnels ou les CAP les
apprentissages il y a pas assez de place
il y a beaucoup de les places sont très
restreintes et il y en a pas de partout
en fait et c'est très dur d'avoir une
place pour les personnes qui veulent
justement avoir enfin qui savent ce
qu'ils veulent faire mais qui ne peuvent
pas parce qu'il y a pas de place en fait
il y a non seulement ça je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi Amy et si
on est dans le système scolaire on peut
aussi s'attaquer aux études supérieures
c'est à dire que dans les études
supérieures il y a pas beaucoup de place
dans certaines écoles qui sont pourtant
très prestigieuses alors certes bien sûr
je vous demande pas de mettre plus de
place à Polytechnique mais il y a
certaines écoles où ce serait bien qu'il
y a des aménagements pour qu'elle puisse
être agrandir pour pouvoir accueillir
plus d'élèves et aussi qui est plus
d'aide qui soit qui soit mise en place
pour les étudiants parce que on sait
très bien qu'à l'heure actuelle le
problème de la précarité étudiante c'est
vraiment quelque chose dont on parle
dont on se rend compte que c'est un
problème et pourtant ça bouge pas
énormément donc ce serait vraiment bien
que ça bouge ça aussi pour pas que les
étudiants se retrouvent en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté je crois que Gabin
aussi vous les réagir en France l'État
va souvent dire que les il y a une chute
des moyennes tout ça par rapport aux
élèves mais ils seront pas de compte
parce que en fait on a une trop grosse
surcharge aussi de travail de devoir à
la maison va nous demander de faire
beaucoup de choses on va avoir certains
contrôles beaucoup d'élèves ne
s'intéressent plus à ce qu'ils
apprennent à l'école donc en fait on
[Musique]
bon il est les professeurs de philo sont
un peu défendus par d'autres internautes
qui nous disent qu'au contraire ça
permet d'apprendre à raisonner mais
voilà en tout cas ça fait beaucoup
réagir le fait que se prépare pas assez
à la vie réelle merci beaucoup Aubry
Lauren à ton tour si tu veux en fait moi
je voulais parler aussi du fait que
certes on
généralise beaucoup trop les matières
mais je trouve aussi qu'on nous force
beaucoup trop tôt à choisir un truc que
tu pourras pas changer plus tard faire
un choix d'avenir assez comment dire
conséquent et si je trouve que c'est
beaucoup trop tôt pour faire un choix
pareil
est-ce que tu veux répondre
par rapport à ce que dit l'oral c'est
vrai que on nous demande très tôt de
choisir notre orientation d'aller en
lycée général en lycée professionnel etc
mais le pire je pense c'est quand on
arrive aux études supérieures et qu'on
nous demande bah au lycée en première en
choisissant nos spécialités premièrement
et ensuite en terminale de choisir nos
facs nos écoles etc et en fait une fois
qu'on a choisi qu'on est dans ces mais
dans ces écoles on n'aime pas forcément
et en fait c'est je trouve très mal vu
de la comment on dit ça ouais de se
réorienter vers quelque chose d'autre on
dit qu'on a loupé notre année que c'est
une année en moins que et c'est vraiment
très mal vu et je trouve ça vraiment
dommage parce qu'en fait ça nous apprend
déjà quelque chose parce que une année
c'est jamais perdue je pense et donc
voilà
parce que c'est vrai qu'on nous demande
très tôt de faire un choix important
pour notre avenir de savoir ce qu'on
veut faire de notre vie tout ça mais en
même temps je trouve que ça assez
contradictoire parce que on nous propose
pas tellement de choses pour découvrir
plein de métiers tout ça je trouve que
c'est pas assez vaste en dehors je sais
pas du stage de troisième par exemple on
nous propose pas assez
par exemple d'intervention de personnes
qui travaillent dans ça ou ça pour nous
expliquer leur métier
d'accord quelqu'un d'autre non
oui comme ils ont tous dit peut-être
réduire certaines heures qui pourraient
ne pas intéresser des élèves par exemple
l'histoire il y a la culture à savoir
qu'on a déjà acquis au collège pour ceux
qui veulent l'approfondir ils peuvent
rester mais pour ceux qui ne veulent pas
spécialement peut-être trouver d'autres
heures où il pourrait trouver des
activités qui pourraient leur permettre
de découvrir de nouvelles bases de
nouveaux métiers qui pourraient leur
plaire pour la suite et même ou d'autres
activités tout autre qui leur servirait
plus tard et
trouver une de quelque chose qui
vraiment d'hiver pour que ça plaise
vraiment à tout le monde et que tout le
monde trouve leur compte au final merci
Rachel Achille tu as quelque chose à
dire Gabin en fait aussi ce qui
ce qui porte beaucoup de comment ce qui
déplaît beaucoup aux jeunes de notre de
notre âge ça va être sur le fait qu'on
va nous demander beaucoup de diplômes
tout ça pour pouvoir intégrer un travail
plus tard de faire beaucoup d'études
tout ça alors qu'on sait même pas ce
qu'on veut et en fait ça va peut-être
revenir comme dans les années 50 tout ça
il y avait une sur qualification de tout
le monde et beaucoup tous les étudiants
avaient plein de diplômes et se
retrouvaient à faire le café parce qu'il
y avait trop de trop leur demander de
savoir trop de choses par rapport à la
tâche qu'on a leur demander de savoir et
de cumuler les années d'études tout ça
et pour ça pour les choix de métiers
plus tard et tout ça des facultés tout
ça on va nous parler de parcoursup mon
nom n'est pas première enfin les
premières on n'est pas concernés
principalement je pense surtout au
terminal qui vont être le plus concernés
par rapport à parcoursup qu'ils auraient
quelque chose à dire justement ouais on
a des petites questions dans le public
obérissent que tu peux aller tendre le
micro
il y a quelque pas à faire pour arriver
jusque là-bas c'est un petit peu loin
alors qui qui veut parler tout de suite
quelque chose c'était pour répondre à
Rachel je crois qui a parlé de
l'histoire du fait que c'était pas
forcément quelque chose d'important moi
je rejoins ce qu'elle a dit sur le fait
qu'il y a des matières qui sont enfin
qui sont pas très importantes surtout
quand on a en terminale par exemple et
qu'on va on se dirige vraiment vers nos
études supérieures mais j'avoue que je
pensais plus par exemple bon moi je suis
littéraire après donc c'est un peu
compliqué mais par exemple un
enseignement scientifique même ceux qui
font en fait qui font des matières
scientifiques il s'intéressent même pas
au cours en fait c'est vraiment une
matière qui au final c'est un peu la
cour de récréation et à la place de ça
on devrait plutôt avoir des heures pour
travailler ou des heures par exemple
pour nous apprendre tout ce qui est
administration tout ce qui est factures
et tout bon genre raffole pas mais
justement en attendant après je sais que
enfin il y aura forcément un moment là
où je vais devoir apprendre à faire ça
alors autant la prendre de plus tôt
possible voilà
merci
bon allez on revient par ici Achille je
crois justement tu voulais réagir aussi
alors oui je voulais rebondir sur ce
qu'avait dit sur le fait que on a une
mauvaise vision de nous-mêmes et une
mauvaise vision de la part des autres
quand on redouble ou quand on se
réoriente mais on a aussi souvent une
vision un peu péjorative des autres
quand on part dans un bac pro par
exemple un ST2A un sthr un STMG je sais
pas pourquoi c'est si mal vu de pas être
en général mais faut vraiment ça c'est
plus un message aux gens de notre âge du
coup faut vraiment arrêter de voir les
gens en filière pro comme des gens qui
moins intelligents ils font juste autre
chose
[Musique]
si vous êtes d'accord avec les cours
est-ce que c'est court même qu'on vous
donne est-ce que vous voulez trouver
adapté ce qu'il vous plaisent et ce
qu'on enseigne c'est vraiment ce que
vous avez envie de savoir danser là
Joris tu veux répondre bah moi je suis
assez d'accord avec la personne qui a
parlé dans le public dans la mesure où
l'enseignement scientifique en fait ça
dessert un petit peu à tout le monde
dans le sens où ceux qui ont déjà des
spécialités scientifiques on leur
rajoute deux heures de tronc commun
d'enseignement scientifique ils en ont
pas forcément besoin parce qu'ils en ont
déjà assez et au contraire les personnes
littéraires n'ont pas de spécialités
scientifiques on leur met quand même
deux heures de sciences dans les pattes
et je pense que ça les desserts plus
qu'autre chose
bah merci beaucoup Joris personne
d'autre
non ben je pense qu'on va peut-être pas
ça la prochaine thématique
tranquillement aller
ah mais ouais je voulais dire quelque
chose
l'avait dit
on est très peu renseigné sur les
différents métiers qu'il y a on nous
aurons plutôt vers des métiers basiques
comme médecin
professeur alors qui a tout plein
d'autres métiers dont on connaît même
pas l'existence et qui pourrait
peut-être plaire à chacun d'entre nous
que que médecin enfin bon on en a besoin
mais il y en a d'autres qui aimeraient
peut-être par exemple comme Achille
l'avait dit travailler dans dans la et
c'est très peu c'est très peu valorisé
par rapport à d'autres secteurs de
métiers d'accord merci beaucoup parce
que quelqu'un veut rajouter quelque
chose non
bon cette fois-ci
alors pour cette deuxième thématique on
va on va comme toi tu en parlais déjà
Laurane on va parler de santé mentale
maintenant et on a pour ça un petit
module qu'on va vous présenter alors ce
sont deux témoignages de jeunes
étudiants qui nous racontent avoir vécu
du harcèlement lorsqu'ils étaient au
collège et qui expliquent l'impact que
ça sur leur vie jusqu'aujourd'hui ils
ont plus de 20 ans et cet impact est
encore fort je vous propose qu'on les
écoute maintenant
j'ai 22 ans et j'ai subi ce qu'on
appelle du harcèlement quand j'étais en
sixième cinquième moi j'ai 23 ans et les
classes sur lesquelles mes problèmes de
harcèlement scolaire ce sont déroulés
c'est la 6e 5e et un peu le début à 4e
et ça s'arrête après ça a commencé avec
une bande de copines qui sont un petit
peu retournée contre moi car l'une
d'elles a vu quand j'étais chez elle que
je portais un soutien-gorge avec du
rembourrage donc les moqueries ont
commencé avec ça mon frère et moi on
était assez enrobé à l'époque j'étais
pas grand non plus j'ai des petites
lunettes ovales
plus elles ont un peu répondu les
rumeurs pour que les gens donc de ma
classe et aussi les autres sixième les
autres 5e ne me parlent plus non plus ça
a commencé par des paroles donc le gros
lard le surnom Harry Potter
et puis ça ça s'est en venimeux au fur
et à mesure du temps plus ça va plus ces
gens là ont de la confiance et plus ça
devient violent c'était assez difficile
parce que je devais manger seul à la
cantine aussi pendant les récrés bah
c'est toujours la honte des tout seul je
passais ces pauses toutes seules dans
les toilettes parce que c'était mieux
d'être toute seule dans les toilettes
que de montrer à tout le monde que
j'étais toute seule je me suis retrouvée
plaqué contre des murs en me disant
qu'on allait me péter le nez et que à la
fin j'allais pas rester debout
harcèlement m'a changé
de tel que j'ai pas confiance en moi
faut beaucoup de mental et ceux qui
arrivent sont très très forts je sais
que j'arrive à passer un peu plus au
dessus de ça maintenant mais aussi j'ai
vraiment du mal à accorder ma confiance
ça me racontait aux gens je sociabilise
mais vraiment j'ai du mal à me livrer
totalement on va dire que je me prive de
correction optique pour
pour toujours ce qu'en fait je pourrais
jamais remettre des lunettes je pense ça
me bloque ça me bloque trop c'est de
l'appréhension c'est un peu presque de
la peur en fait ça joue encore
aujourd'hui dans des situations comme
par exemple avoir un nouveau travail ou
vraiment j'ai du mal à être en confiance
ou j'ai vraiment besoin d'être accepté
directement ou sinon je suis dans des
phases de doux tout je me dis que jamais
je vais être accepté par mes collègues
etc donc c'est assez compliqué voir le
regard des gens te regarder de haut en
bas voir ah il est pas habillé comme moi
il y a un problème il a un tatouage ou à
des choses comme ça c'est c'est des
choses qui sont assez dures même si on
peut pas tout de suite penser
penser que ça peut être lié à du
harcèlement scolaire au départ
alors vous l'avez vu en ces deux
témoignages mais juste avant de faire
réagir les lycéens on va aller voir
Aubery je crois qu'il avait des petites
questions encore dans le chat qui
mettent un peu de temps à arriver avec
la latence mais on va y répondre donc
Aubery plein de questions vraiment un
chat très actif et une petite question
effectivement qui a mis un petit peu de
temps à arriver c'est Marc qui dit que
justement par rapport au fait que vous
ayez des journées trop longues un peu
beaucoup de cours et que c'était
difficile de suivre le rythme et bien
que vous passiez trop de temps sur votre
téléphone et que c'est pour ça que vous
arriviez pas à vous organiser j'ai
l'impression que ça fait beaucoup réagir
chez vous aussi
ça a fait très réagir ici tout le monde
a soufflé
ce que vous êtes d'accord je pense que
je vais commencer ma phrase comme ça va
falloir arrêter avec ce cliché du jeune
qui est tout le temps sur son téléphone
déjà papa va falloir oublier que pour
nous un téléphone c'est aussi un outil
de travail comme l'ordinateur l'a été
quelques années après son apparition
comme les livres l'ont été avant et les
papiers même si personnellement j'aime
bien le papier mais par exemple pour
prendre note sur cette émission et
certains utilisateur téléphone donc
quand on est sur notre téléphone faut
pas croire qu'on est tout le temps en
train d'envoyer un message ça nous
arrive d'envoyer des messages comme ça
doit vous arriver aussi vous qui vous
regardez qui nous regardez mais souvent
on bosse on regarde des trucs pour se
renseigner par exemple je sais que mes
sources pour les thèmes d'après je les
ai principalement trouvé à partir de
vidéo de médias sur les réseaux sociaux
etc etc donc le téléphone c'est plus un
outil de travail je pense que un
un outil pour de divertissement c'est
c'est les deux mais c'est surtout un
travail pour nous je pense
quelqu'un d'autre voulait réagir à cette
phrase qui a pas trop plu ce sont le
chat je crois
écoutez je propose qu'on retourne à nos
à nos deux témoignages voilà pour
rebondir sur cette vidéo émy cet impact
justement du harcèlement dans votre
scolarité toi comment tu comment tu le
vois et comment tu l'as peut-être vécu
aussi bah moi je sais que j'ai vécu du
harcèlement quand j'étais en 3e et ça a
été très dur à vivre parce que je me
suis vraiment retrouvée toute seule
contre beaucoup de personnes et
à ce moment là je me rendais pas
forcément compte que c'était du
harcèlement je pensais que c'était juste
des petites taquineries etc et en fait
je me suis rendu compte plus tard quand
je suis arrivée en seconde et que j'ai
trouvé un climat plus sain qu'en fait
bah oui c'était bien du harcèlement ce
que j'ai vécu et même encore aujourd'hui
bah j'ai perdu confiance en moi j'ai
peur du regard des autres et c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui impacte nos
vies et comme les témoignages l'ont dit
peut-être même pendant très longtemps
quoi
Gabin je crois que tu veux réagir faut
pas oublier que toutes les formes de
harcèlement de moquerie tout ça ça peut
souvent rester très profondément ancré
dans la tête de la personne à qui on va
les dire et ça peut causer des comme ça
a été dit dans les dans les modules
juste avant ça peut causer des des
traumatismes ou des choses comme ça ou
des peurs à arriver à l'âge adulte de ce
montrer en public de parler devant des
autres parce que on a été trop réfrénées
étant au collège tout ça parce que les
enfants sont très méchants moqueur entre
eux et ça marque beaucoup de personnes
sans qu'on s'en rende compte les
personnes ne se parle pas forcément de
ce qu'elle ressentent ça c'est bien
dommage mais on peut pas savoir ce qui
se passe dans la tête de quelqu'un si on
l'a blessé ou pas donc pour faudrait
mieux éviter les remarques trop
blessantes
Rachel
sauf que du coup quand une fois qu'on
les a
déterminés c'est ce sentiment
d'harcèlement etc une fois qu'on a tout
enfant nous on aimerait trouver des
solutions et souvent ça arrive à l'âge
du lycée etc sauf qu'à partir de là on
en fonction des personnes on est plus ou
moins aidé que ce soit parfois des
professeurs des petits au lycée ou même
des adultes en général ils sont là mais
pour eux ce n'est ils vont prendre ça
plus ou moins la légère et parfois ça
aide pas vraiment la personne et ça
retombe des années après sur leur impact
physique ou mental donc faudrait trouver
des solutions le plus tôt possible sauf
que pour ça faudrait que certaines
personnes le prennent plus conscience
que c'est important et de nous aider à
aller mieux le plus vite
Gabin aussi je voulais rajouter quelque
chose vous qui nous écoutez chez vous si
vous pensez à avoir du harcèlement vous
sentez pas bien tout ça il faut en
parler les enfin les jeunes il y a plus
de 8 jeunes sur 10 qui ne se confie pas
un professionnel qui en parle que à ses
amis et ce qui va causer qui va il va
ruminer va penser tout le temps la même
chose et ça peut arriver avec
l'accumulation de d'énergie négative de
tristesse d'harcèlement tout ça ça peut
causer des choses comme la dépression
qui est une maladie faut pas prendre ces
choses là aussi enfin
faut prendre ces choses là au sérieux et
puis ne pas négliger toutes vos
mauvaises pensées ça a été trop
normalisé de pas se sentir bien mais
c'est pas normal c'est quand vous êtes
chez vous vous sentez pas bien que vous
préférez au lycée ou inversement si vous
venez au lycée la boule au ventre même
au collège faut en parler faut en parler
des professionnels donc des
professionnels de type psychologues
psychiatre tout ça des personnes qui
pourront vous aider vous pouvez vous
allez voir votre médecin traitant ou des
choses comme ça vous demandez à vos
parents à Alicia tu voulais dire quelque
chose aussi moi c'était pour rajouter
un chiffre avec ce que Gabin vient de
dire j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait 16% de
suicides dû à l'harcèlement entre les
personnes de 15 à 24 ans
et je vais rebondir même si c'est pas
drôle du tout mais je vais rebondir sur
le suicide ce qui se passe souvent avec
le harcèlement c'est qu'on a peur d'en
parler autour de nous à des adultes à
des responsables et je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce que Gabin a dit
n'hésitez surtout pas à en parler parce
qu'on va avoir un certain syndrome de
l'imposteur c'est à dire se dire oui
mais j'exagère peut-être que c'est pas
si grave peut-être que je prends juste
tout mal sauf que la plupart du temps
bah c'est pas le cas on va aussi avoir
peur des répercussions de la part des
harceleurs sur si on dit quelque chose
sur ce qui nous font et ça peut être
grave et ça peut conduire à des grosses
grosses conséquences sur la santé
physique et mentale des personnes qui
sont harcelées et voilà donc faut
vraiment en parler je crois que Lorraine
tu voulais ajouter quelque chose
alors comment dire
si justement quand je me suis fait
harceler déjà non seulement j'en ai
parlé à mes parents bon ça a pas été
réglé mais c'est pas grave mais la
première chose que je me suis dit en
arrivant au lycée enfin au fil du temps
je me suis dit en fait les remarques des
gens on s'en moque c'est un message que
j'ai envie de faire passer là le
remarque des gens on s'en moque qu'il y
en aura toujours un pour te dire que ça
va pas que c'est pas bien et la seule
personne que tu dois croire c'est
toi-même
et j'aimerais aussi ajouter que le
harcèlement dans les établissements en
fait ils mettent des affiches top
warcellement ne harcelez pas vos
camarades mais ça fait rien en fait ça
leur fait pas peur faudrait songer
peut-être à prendre d'autres mesures
parce que moi par exemple j'en ai parlé
à la CPE elle m'a elle m'a regardé elle
a dit tu en es sûr
et du coup bah je pense qu'il faudrait
quand même appliquer d'autres mesures
d'autres je sais que ce sera
probablement jamais assez mais faut
essayer de tenter d'autres trucs que des
affiches ou des interventions
tu veux rajouter quelque chose aussi
moi je dis je suis totalement d'accord
sur le fait avec tout le monde sur le
fait qu'il faut parler c'est très
important mais je trouve qu'il n'y a pas
assez de psychologues ou de psychiatre
dans notre société je prends encore un
exemple personnel j'ai été voir une
psychiatre qui ne me convenait pas parce
que oui des psychiatres ne conviennent
pas à tout le monde et j'ai voulu aller
en voir un à l'hôpital qui est juste à
côté à Semur et en fait on sait tous
sectorisés donc il y a au moins il y a
au moins bien cinq psychiatres
et ils ont pas voulu me prendre parce
que c'était sectorisé donc je dois aller
sur Dijon Dijon qui a une heure et demie
de chez moi donc c'est pas possible
d'avoir un suivi régulier sur Dijon pour
moi donc je ne peux pas être prise en
charge en fait donc je trouve ça
vraiment grave que
il y a des psychiatres à côté de chez
nous mais qu'on puisse pas être pris en
compte quoi
merci beaucoup Emy je crois que du côté
du chat aussi ça a fait réagir cette
thématique au bruit oui alors on a mode
qui nous dit qu'elle n'est pas d'accord
sur le fait que en tant qu'adulte on
prend ça la légère c'est juste qu'on
manque de formation pour détecter les
signes de harcèlement ce à quoi Marie
lui répond je ne sais pas si les
personnels éducatifs sont mieux formés
au harcèlement qu'avant certains enfants
brise le silence mais des surveillants
au CPE sont incompétents qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous pensez que on vous
écoute mais c'est juste qu'on ne sait
pas le faire au contraire qu'on a un
compétent
pour moi je pense que les parents
d'élèves enfin les parents en général
s'intéressent beaucoup à la santé de
leurs enfants enfin la plupart certains
parents ne sont pas à ça mais beaucoup
de parents s'intéressent à la santé de
leurs enfants mais comme a dit Achille
certains n'osent pas du tout en parler
juste parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
déranger ils ont pas envie de que leurs
parents sont tristes pensent qu'ils ont
mal fait les choses ou les déranger tout
ça dans leur travail parce que leurs
parents travaillent déjà beaucoup ils ne
veulent pas leur rajouter de la charge
émotionnelle supplémentaire
comme j'ai dit il y a beaucoup de jeunes
qui ne se confient pas et par exemple
j'ai des personnes qui des amis à moi
qui sont venues me confier et certaines
personnes qui m'ont dit qu'ils voulaient
se suicider des propos très graves et
qu'ils ont qui pensaient réellement et
n'ont jamais parlé à leurs parents je
peux pas aller parler à leurs parents
leur place c'est pas quelque chose qui
se fait et ils veulent pas ils se
sentent pas donc ça se trouve il y a des
gens dans le chat vos enfants vont pas
bien ils ont juste pas vous le dire et
c'est plutôt à vous de faire une
démarche et d'aller vers eux essayer de
leur parler doucement ne pas les
brusquer d'un coup sur le sujet c'est de
voir comment ils se sentent parce que en
fait là depuis 2018 plus de enfin le
suicide chez les filles de moins de 15
ans a augmenté de 40% depuis 2018 ce qui
est un chiffre énorme et ça c'est juste
parce que la plupart n'osent pas en
parler donc je voulais aussi donner des
numéros est-ce que j'ai le droit des
numéros de des numéros verts en question
il y a filtrant tes jeunes c'est 0,800
235 236 suicide écoute au 01 45 39 40 00
et au 31 3 14 le numéro national de
prévention du suicide donc si jamais
vous êtes quelqu'un qui se sent pas bien
qui ne sait pas qui en parlait sont des
professionnels qui pourront vous écouter
vous rediriger vers des autres
professionnels compétents pour aider
votre cas
merci Gabin alors on va continuer de
parler de cette thématique Laurane tu
veux peut-être ajouter quelque chose
il y avait d'abord Alicia pardon vas-y
expérience j'avais une personne très
proche de moi qui au collège a reçu
beaucoup de critiques à cause de son
poids et cette personne était aussi
forte à l'école donc il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont joué et qui lors de qui lui
demandait des devoirs et tout par
exemple et à l'heure actuelle bah aller
toucher de TCA et c'était pour montrer
que ça marque et que ça peut revenir
dans le futur parce que quitter le
collège déjà depuis plus de 6 ans
moi donc j'aimerais juste rebondir sur
la question des de la formation des
adultes par rapport au harcèlement
j'aimerais parler d'une amie qui est
arrivée dans mon collège donc en
cinquième et c'est très vite farcelé
parce que elle avait des particularités
physiques elle avait un accent
particulier puisque elle venait pas
d'ici et en fait j'ai si je puis dire
harceler les surveillants de rapport je
leur ai dit que mon ami se faisait
harceler ils ont mis deux ans à agir
c'est donc je pense pas qu'à ce niveau
là ce soit une histoire de formation ou
pas parce que quand tu mets deux ans
agir pour une élève qui se sent
tellement mal mais
Achille
par rapport à ce que disait Alicia faut
aussi savoir que c'est pas un cas isolé
le fait de souffrir de troubles du
comportement alimentaire type anorexie
boulimie hyperphagie après avoir subi un
harcèlement sur son poids je vais
peut-être partager quelque chose de
personnel mais ça m'est arrivé aussi et
les conséquences peuvent être tellement
graves dans le temps que là j'approche
mes 18 ans j'ai été harcelée disons de
mes disons 6 à 13 ans et que aujourd'hui
tous les matins quand je me regarde dans
le miroir je me demande si on va me
trouver gros à l'école alors que je sais
pertinemment que j'ai un poids normal et
encore normal et c'est vraiment des
choses qui vont marquer les gens à vie
et ça peut coûter des années de thérapie
et ça peut même coûter la vie à
certaines personnes qui vont se dire
soit ok bah si je me suicide ils vont
arrêter de me harceler soit ok bah si je
me suicide ils vont arrêter de me
harceler et en plus ils verront à quel
point ils m'ont fait mal donc vraiment
même si vous pensez que c'est une toute
petite chose que vous dites et que ça
pourra jamais faire de mal à la personne
si ça peut faire extrêmement mal et vous
avez pas idée à quel point certaines
personnes en reçoivent tous les jours de
10 personnes différentes qui sont tous
plus mal les unes que les autres de
critiques donc soyez juste gentil avec
les gens vous savez pas ce qui vous
quotidien faut être bienveillant à un
moment
merci Achille Joris tu voulais aussi
rebondir sur quelque chose oui
j'aimerais clore un petit peu ce petit
cette petite case d'harcèlement et avant
ça aimerait quand même demander à Alicia
qu'est-ce que c'est un TCA parce que pas
tout le monde c'est ce que c'est
même même moi par exemple je sais pas
trop ce que c'est
[Musique]
du comportement alimentaire donc c'est
type anorexie hyperphagie boulimie donc
l'anorexie c'est ce privé de manger
à peu près
nonorexie donc c'est un trouble mental
donc déjà il y a pas de cordes nordiques
quelqu'un d'honorexique peut être en
surpoids oui ça surprend mais c'est
comme ça donc l'anorexie ça va être le
principe de vouloir à tout prix maigrir
donc vraiment il y a des privations de
nourriture il peut y avoir aussi des
vomissements la boulimie ça va être le
fait de manger jusqu'à ce que enfin les
quantités astronomiques jusqu'à ce que
bah il est vomissement ou vomissements
volontaire et l'hyperphagie ça va juste
être le fait de se remplir
volontairement pour sentir quelque chose
en général il y a d'autres cas et
d'autres motifs d'hyperphagie mais ça va
être principalement ça et c'est pas
nécessairement vos métiers
merci Achille c'est pas quelqu'un
d'autre veut encore réagir on va
peut-être plus revenir vers le chat au
Berry je crois que ça continue de
répondre sur ce sujet il y a beaucoup de
témoignages donc ouais ça continue ça
continue de répondre et justement on
revient à ce qui se disait tout à
l'heure au sujet des harceleurs il y a
quelqu'un qui nous disait que peut-être
aussi que les harceleurs il se rendait
pas compte en tant que tel que ils
étaient harceleur j'ai juste il faisait
une petite blague et il se rendait pas
compte de l'impact que ça pouvait avoir
sur les gens qu'est-ce que vous en dites
de ça vous
Gabin
en fait le problème c'est justement ça
c'est plein de gens ne se rendent pas
compte et on ne peut pas leur rejeter la
faute dessus parce que pour certaines
personnes ça va être il va avoir fait
une remarque à quelqu'un une fois dans
sa vie sauf que cette personne dans la
même journée comme a dit Achille va
recevoir 10 remarques de 10 autres
personnes différentes voire plus et ça
continue tous les jours donc une
remarque de plus ça peut beaucoup
changer
donc juste une seule remarque la
personne va pas se rendre compte c'est
pas du harcèlement là mais juste de se
moquer quelqu'un on peut penser c'est le
Titi un peu le on va le taquiner tout ça
mais enfin par certaines personnes ça
peut être vu comme comme des comme des
moqueries des choses comme ça et on
n'ose pas souvent parler dire que ça
nous blesse et tout ça et c'est ça qui
va conduire à du harcèlement c'est plus
le ressenti de la personne plus que
l'acte que le harceleur fait donc pour
ça faut plus parler aux personnes
exemple si vous voulez rigoler un peu
avec un copain tout ça vous c'est votre
ami proche et vous lui dites tu as pris
un petit peu de poids tout ça dites-lui
demandez-lui bien si ça l'a pas vexé
honnêtement dites-lui est-ce que ça t'a
vexé ou est-ce que je peux rigoler ou
vraiment ça touche sache que je veux pas
du mal et ça va être plus des
préventions comme ça la faire contre une
personne à qui on va faire adresser une
petite moquerie gentille voilà
merci Gabin Rachel tu as quelque chose
d'ajouter juste avant aussi parce que
maintenant on est un peu plus conscience
que parfois des mots ont plus de
conséquences contrairement aux collèges
où on a tendance à encore plus à partir
de là qui a beaucoup plus de
d'harcèlement et on en a pas conscience
et je pense qu'il faudrait que ce soit
les enseignants ou d'autres personnes
nous rabâche un peu plus parce que
certes on a une fois dans l'année
quelqu'un qui vient nous parler de
harcèlement quoi que ce soit mais on en
a pas conscience que si peut-être si on
nous le répéter un peu plus souvent dans
l'année que bah il y a des conséquences
que ça fait du mal aux certaines
personnes on prendrait plus conscience à
être plus bienveillant envers les autres
ce qui est peut-être réduirait aussi le
taux de harcèlement parce que
il faudrait éviter
Laurane moi je pense surtout que les
harceleurs se rendent pas compte de leur
blague parce que en général un être
humain je vais généraliser un être
humain voit sa vie ses problèmes et pas
le fait que les autres peuvent en avoir
aussi peuvent être les acteurs de leur
vie à eux et du coup pour eux en fait
une petite remarque c'est rien alors que
bah justement
une remarque peut tout changer
merci Laurent Gabin autre chose je
voulais dire aussi après faut pas non
plus des dramatiser le fait d'harceler
quelqu'un ça peut être comme on l'a dit
ne pas se rendre compte mais il y a
aussi des personnes l'année dernière
j'étais dans un autre lycée j'ai vu des
personnes se faire harceler je leur ai
dit d'aller en parler mais c'était du
harcèlement très violent c'est à dire à
base de pousser de pousser par terre
lancer des sacs dans la tête claquer des
portes au nez insulter devant tout le
monde et c'est des choses très violentes
et ça m'étonne que ça a été fait devant
des enseignants du corps enseignant cet
effet devant des surveillants qui n'ont
même pas réagi et là il y a vraiment un
problème dans dans le sens où c'est pas
ne pas être formé c'est ne pas avoir de
sens moral quand on laisse des élèves
être aussi violents on peut dire eux ils
sont juste amis se taquine mais là c'est
plus des taquineries à partir du moment
où il y a des coups violents
merci Alicia tu veux rajouter quelque
chose je voulais juste rajouter que on
parle beaucoup de harcèlement au collège
mais il peut aussi être présent en école
maternelle et primaire je connais une
personne qui s'est fait harceler en
maternelle et qui a continué à en
primaire et par contre au collège ça a
été
on a arrêté de la harceler ou des choses
comme ça donc il faut pas penser que ce
soit juste au collège et que ça peut
arriver beaucoup plus tôt et du coup
même les enfants qui sont jeunes il faut
aussi leur en parler et leur prévenir
dessus
merci Alicia on va juste prendre une
petite réaction dans le public je crois
qu'il y a certaines personnes qui
aimeraient parler au Berry qui est
justement oui je suis juste là avec
Mathilde elle a une petite question au
sujet de des harceleur donc je lui
laisse la parole c'est juste le
commentaire il m'a fait réagir parce que
le VTT que les personnes au collège ou
même au lycée se rendent pas forcément
compte de ce qui se passe de juste c'est
une blague c'est drôle c'est bon ça va
pas très loin c'est enfin on parle
beaucoup bah les déjà je trouve que les
les personnes
je vais y arriver qui sont formés au
lycée ils sont pas assez formés en fait
les professeurs les CPE tout ça mais
pour moi le premier travail ça commence
quand même avec les parents et je sais
que des fois on se rend pas forcément
compte que c'est super dur déjà d'élever
un enfant et tout et surtout lui
inculquer le fait que c'est pas drôle en
fait de dire à son pote qu'il est drôle
enfin qu'il est gros genre de choses et
tout c'est très banalisé à l'école mais
aussi à l'extérieur dans la famille
entre les frères et sœurs par exemple ce
sont des blagues qui sont souvent faites
et tout et je trouve qu'on en parle pas
assez voilà
une petite réaction du côté là-bas de
nos lycéens
à l'école ça peut être fait dans la rue
des gens qu'on ne connaît pas des
remarques bon c'est moins courant si ça
peut être dans la famille c'est vrai que
même des parents s'en rendent compte
peuvent taquiner un enfant en disant tu
manges beaucoup ce soir et tout ça
qu'est-ce que tu en appétit de ouf fais
gaffe à pas prendre du poids ou alors tu
manges pas des choses comme ça faire des
remarques ça peut être pour des parents
juste histoire de créer du lien avec
leurs enfants mais ils se rendent pas
compte que derrière ça les touche
beaucoup aussi peut avoir du harcèlement
au travail on peut parler il y a aussi
des adultes qui se font harceler c'est
pas exclusivement des problèmes
d'enfants voilà sinon je vais dire autre
chose mais là ça m'est sorti de la tête
on va reposer une autre question moi
j'avais une question à vous poser
justement vous parlez beaucoup de ces
adultes et des réactions qu'ils ont
qu'est-ce que vous voulez vous qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez qu'il fasse notamment
sur ce sujet là
Laurent tu veux répondre
parce que j'aimerais qu'ils prennent
des adéquats dans le sens où je sais pas
par exemple donner des heures de colle
voire des renvoies de plusieurs jours
dans les cas les plus extrêmes suite au
harcèlement parce que
Achille tu veux répondre aussi alors
Laurane je vais te répondre par quelque
chose de très simple dans la loi le
harcèlement c'est puni c'est de la
prison et une amende qui est très
conséquente j'ai pas les chiffres là
tout de suite sauf que le truc c'est que
ce n'est pas appliqué et crois-moi bien
que c'est pas avec quelques jours de
renvoi qu'un harceleur arrête d'harceler
quand c'est un harceleur comme j'en ai
connu
c'est quelque chose de renvoi assez
glace à la fraise pour lui vraiment il
s'en fiche complètement donc là vraiment
ce qu'il faut c'est que la police prenne
les choses en compte parce que je
connais quelqu'un je suis pas allé
personnellement je connais quelqu'un qui
est allé dénoncer à la police le
harcèlement et ils ont dit que les
preuves n'étaient pas suffisante alors
que la personne se faisait littéralement
tabasser donc là c'est surtout des
problèmes de police qui ne fait rien qui
ne prend pas les cas de harcèlement en
compte parce que on a rarement vu des
harceleurs comme il y en a des centaines
et des centaines dans les collèges
lycées école primaire aller en prison
aller en maison de redressement ou payer
une amende parce que ce n'est pas pris
en compte comme beaucoup de choses ne
sont pas pris en compte alors qu'elles
sont écrites noires sur blanc dans le
code pénal
aussi tu as envie de réagir on parlait
justement mais enfin Achille nous parler
du harcèlement qui était pas forcément
puni en fait le harcèlement dans dans
les collèges dans les lycées tout ça ça
va être quelque chose de très difficile
à prendre en charge parce que je connais
des gens aussi ils se sont fait harceler
et ils ont ils ont parlé au système du
lycée tout ça on leur a dit ah non mais
c'est pas notre problème enfin vous avez
pas de preuve quoi et du coup les
soi-disant de personnes qui se faisaient
harceler enfin qui harceleur une de ces
personnes là étaient le fils du maire du
village du coup le lycée ne voulait pas
avoir de soucis avec le père en disant
que son fils était potentiellement un
harceleur du coup il avait fait passer
ça sous le tapis
et ça a conduit à cette personne là ce
déscolariser la personne qui était
harcelée donc on a parlé du suicide
aussi à la déscolarisation et comme on a
vu tout à l'heure les personnes qui sont
toujours très mal à des années après et
la déscolarisation est un fait qu'il
gâche la vie suite à du harcèlement donc
faut prendre en compte aussi ces
choses-là
merci Gabin on peut vous voulez qu'on
continue sur ce sujet oui Alicia moi
j'ai juste un dernier truc à dire je
voudrais plutôt parler aux gens de notre
âge je pense qu'on serait tous d'accord
aujourd'hui ici pour dire que nos amis
bah c'est une grande force psychologique
pour nous et je voulais dire à vous de
faire attention à vos amis autour de
vous parce que bah par exemple moi j'ai
perdu mes deux parents en moins d'un an
et je sais que bah excusez-moi mes amis
ça a été
pas soucis
pour moi
et que du coup vous
autour de vous faites attention à vos
amis parce que
c'est très très important
merci beaucoup Alicia merci beaucoup et
oui parce que la santé mentale c'est pas
c'est aussi le harcèlement mais c'est
aussi ce qu'on vit avec ses parents avec
sa famille avec ses proches Gabin tu
veux réagir là-dessus aussi
Joris pardon c'est vrai oui oui moi
c'est pas totalement directement lié à
l'harcèlement mais je trouve que dans un
cadre plus scolaire on met beaucoup de
pression aussi sur les jeunes par
rapport à certaines épreuves ou
certaines évaluations
par exemple je pense aux épreuves du bac
où il y a pas mal d'élèves qui se
mettent énormément à la pression jusqu'à
faire des crises d'angoisse ce genre de
choses dans le sens où si par exemple il
rate leur épreuve et ben leur année leur
a servi à rien que leurs études sont
finies que ils doivent tout recommencer
de zéro
pas forcément
voilà j'ai oublié ce que je voulais dire
si ça revient dessus on reviendra vers
toi si mais oui on avait parlé du
harcèlement mais c'est aussi des choses
qui vont conduire à une mauvaise santé
mentale chez les jeunes comme le système
et du gaz natif comme on a parlé juste
avant qui écoute pas c'est les jeunes et
qui force beaucoup les choses par
exemple aux examens et tout ça même un
contrôle tout basique qui peut arriver
une fois par semaine il y a des élèves
qui ont fait des crises d'angoisse comme
nous a dit Joris et c'est trop banalisé
ce fait qu'un élève sortant pleurant
d'un cours parce qu'il a peur de pas
réussir d'avoir une mauvaise note c'est
c'est que rendez-vous compte ne pas
réussir juste avoir une mauvaise note
dans sa moyenne ça ça fait ça fait
pleurer des personnes en larmes ça les
fait faire des crises de tétanie il y en
a certaines qui s'évanouissent juste à
cause de ça donc là il y a quand même à
une bonne question à se poser par
rapport au fait qu'il y a une grosse
pression et les parents aussi certains
parents qui nous écoutent vous rendez
peut-être pas compte mais certains
peuvent dire à leurs enfants oui tu as
eu combien tout ça et en fait ça ça les
force à se donner au maximum pour vous
parce que la plupart vous faire plaisir
veulent être que vous soyez fier d'eux
il faut leur dire que vous êtes fier de
parce que c'est quelque chose on en
parle pas on parle des amis mais les
parents c'est quelque chose de très
important pour un enfant soyez véridique
l'heure que vous êtes fier et ne leur
parlez pas des choses qui les stressent
déjà beaucoup comme les notes même si je
sais que vous en tant que parents vous
aimeriez que votre enfant réussisse qui
se concentra à l'école et peut-être
qu'il a des problèmes qui ne veut pas
vous parler et qui cacha et vous savez
pas forcément ce qui se passe tétine ne
veut pas vous en parler et s'il veut pas
c'est son choix mais n'essayer de pas
trop forcer sur les sur les courses
c'est quelque chose de très stressant
pour des élèves de notre âge
je vais prendre l'exemple qui date de à
peine une heure ou j'ai je suis sorti
avec une camarade qui s'est mis pour la
je sais pas combien il y a une fois de
l'année une pression astronomique au
point où elle était en crise tétanique
allongée dans le couloir à ne plus
pouvoir respirer les membres
complètement paralysées à vraiment plus
bougeoir à souffrir bouger et à souffrir
etc c'est ça fait plusieurs fois que ça
arrive dans l'année déjà l'infirmière
scolaire arrivée au bout de certains
moments et elle n'est pas sûr que elle
est conscience que
l'école quoi que ce soit et important
mais pas au point de mettre sa santé au
plus bas elle se met une pression
astronomique et je la l'infirmière je
sais pas si elle l'a suit vraiment parce
que
au moins l'aider à descendre sa pression
qu'elle se met à elle-même ce que
vraiment ça peut partir dans des tours
astronomiques juste pour un contrôle qui
était
pas basique mais vous n'avez pas besoin
de se mettre aussi grosse pression et
finir comme ça c'est pas vraiment normal
alors vous parlez beaucoup de des
adultes qui ne vous comprennent pas
forcément mais est-ce que dans votre
dans votre entourage c'est quand même
des adultes qui font qui font l'effort
de venir vous voir ça peut être autre
parent ça peut être dans votre famille
ou même en dehors est-ce que vous sentez
vraiment abandonné ou est-ce qu'il y en
a qui sont quand même présent pour vous
qui arrivent qui essayent de vous
comprendre oui Gabin
je sais que moi par exemple c'est pas le
cas chez moi chez moi je suis très bien
entouré j'étais très bon parent tout ça
qui me comprennent qui me pose des
questions quand ça va pas tout ça ils
sont là et j'aimerais que on les mette
un peu en lumière aussi toutes ces
personnes qui prennent le temps de venir
vers des personnes qui vont pas bien qui
prennent soin d'elle pour leur remonter
le moral tout ça
merci Gabin qui vous a ajouté je voulais
dire par exemple mes parents ils
voudraient bien pouvoir savoir ce qui se
passe il me pose plein de questions il
s'intéresse tout ça mais je veux pas
forcément leur en parler parce que comme
j'ai dit ils ont un travail très
important pour eux ça leur prend
beaucoup de leur temps et j'ai pas envie
de le racheter du stress supplémentaire
j'essaie de gérer ça le mieux possible
par moi-même et chose comme ça il y
avait beaucoup d'adultes qui essayent de
venir voir des élèves des professeurs
certains aussi comme je pense par
exemple notre professeur d'hlp madame
bourse que vous avez sûrement vu la
dernière fois sur France 3 Bourgogne qui
est une professeur qui vient voir la
plupart de ses élèves pour lui demander
comment comment il se sentent si ils
sont pas trop stressés même chez eux
tout ça elle est très à l'écoute de ses
élèves et ça c'est une très bonne
qualité en tant que professeur du coup
on l'a remerci tous je pense déjà
d'avoir organisé ça pour nous tous et de
d'être aussi à l'écoute de tous ces
élèves et bien ça avec Madame bourse que
vous voyez là qu'on a pu préparer cette
émission aussi et qui a toujours été
très présente pour pour eux aussi et
pour préparer ça avec avec beaucoup de
talents aussi
je crois que Alicia tu voulais ajouter
quelque chose aussi moi je voulais dire
pour faire des grandes soeurs c'est
personnellement pour moi c'est beaucoup
plus facile de leur parler ils ont 22
ans et c'est vrai qu'ils comprennent
mieux ce que nous on peut ressentir
parce que ils ont moins d'âge d'écart
avec nous donc si vous avez du mal à
parler avec vos parents peut-être que
votre grand frère va grande sœur pour
être plus vous aider ou même plus loin
peut-être la cousine plus grande que
vous etc mieux vous aider et mieux vous
comprendre
on va peut-être prendre encore une
réaction Gabin tu veux rebondir là
dessus
j'avais pas vu excuse-moi
j'aimerais rajouter quelque chose c'est
et je veux pas faire peur à personne
mais il y a un truc aussi de pourquoi on
peut avoir peur de parler de nos
problèmes mentaux à des gens c'est qu'il
y a beaucoup de psychiatre de
psychologues et même d'enseigne
d'hopitopsychiatrie qui sont dans des je
dis pas qu'ils sont incompétents mais
ils sont dans des valeurs et dans des
enseignements qu'ils ne qui ne sont plus
du tout actuels qui ne sont plus du tout
adaptés à nos besoins actuels en tant
que jeune qui allons mal et
c'est très compliqué quelquefois il y a
des traitements qui sont vraiment pas
acceptés mais comme certains des
établissements privés c'est accepter il
y a ce genre de truc donc je comprends
que ça puisse faire peur après sachez
aussi que si vous avez une mauvaise
expérience avec un psychologue un
psychiatre etc ils ont pas tous comme ça
il y a des psy qui sont vraiment
vraiment très compétents vraiment à
l'écoute qui comprennent il faut
vraiment pas aller enfin pas avoir peur
d'aller vers des professionnels parce
que une fois qu'on trouve quelqu'un avec
qui on s'entend bien qui nous écoute et
qui est prêt à nous aider c'est vraiment
ça aide énormément
qui veut ajouter quelque chose et puis
après on va peut-être aller voir le chat
je voulais dire justement aussi adresser
un message à mes camarades pas forcément
ici mais c'est aussi qui peuvent nous
écouter
la plupart je sais que c'est pas le cas
tous mais vous avez des parents qui
tiennent à vous donc n'hésitez pas à
aller leur parler même s'ils ont un
travail bon je me contredis tout seul
mais si
vous sentez besoin de parler à quelqu'un
vos parents sont souvent là pour vous et
si vos parents ne veulent pas vous
écouter il y a certains parents qui
manquent alors devoir de parents
malheureusement certaines personnes qui
n'ont pas d'amis autrement sachez que
tous les humains on est on est des
animaux des animaux où là une espèce une
espèce sociale et qui reçoit beaucoup
d'empathie je suis sûr là dans la courbe
même d'un lycée si vous allez voir
quelqu'un n'importe qui qui vous semble
avoir une mine sympathique et vous dites
que vous sentez pas bien et vous lui
demandez de vous parler la plupart des
personnes te refuseront pas je sais que
c'est un effort à faire il faut avoir le
courage mais les gens sont très
sympathiques si vous ouvrez à eux il y a
pas que des personnes néfastes
merci beaucoup Gabin on va aller voir du
côté du chat Aubery ouais alors toujours
beaucoup de réactions dans le chat les
gens sont passionnés par votre débat et
beaucoup de personnes qui envoient du
soutien à Alicia sont témoignage très
touchant tout à l'heure beaucoup de gens
aussi qui parlent de Madame bourse comme
étant la meilleure prof sans oublier
monsieur Thévenin aussi le professeur de
philo à côté d'elle et puis on a aussi
quelqu'un qui nous dit que peut-être ça
vous fera réagir que si on fait passer
sa santé avant les cours et ben on va
être pénalisé après pour son dossier je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez si vous
êtes d'accord avec ça ou au contraire si
vous pensez qu'il faut faire attention
levés
vas-y tu peux parler j'aimerais juste
rappeler qu'on parle beaucoup de santé
physique et que du coup la santé mentale
bah il y a le mot santé aussi donc il
faudrait arrêter de bah du coup de faire
passer à santé physique on voit des
médecins souvent mais il faut aussi voir
des psychologues souvent donc oui la
sentin dans les courbes on fait bien
passer notre santé physique parfois
avant les cours on va dispenser de sport
ne pas aller en cours qu'on est malade
bah il faudra faire la même chose pour
la santé mentale si on sent pas bien on
peut ne pas aller en cours donc bien sûr
ça va pas être toujours
toutes les semaines on a le droit de
faire une pause si on se sent pas bien
il faut savoir accepter que notre mental
il a besoin d'une pause et qui va pas
toujours nous suivre
oui je suis complètement d'accord avec
ce qu'a dit etoya c'est moi on m'a
appris totalement l'inverse on m'a dit
tu feras toujours passer ta santé avant
les cours du moins c'est ce que ma mère
m'a appris quand ça a commencé à aller
mal mentalement et effectivement je me
rends compte aujourd'hui maintenant que
je vais mieux que si j'avais pas fait
passer cette santé mentale avant les
cours aujourd'hui je ne serai plus là
pour vous parler donc c'est très
important de faire passer la santé
mentale avant les cours je voulais dire
aussi un gros il y a un gros tabou par
rapport au suivi psychologique comme a
pu le dire avoir un psychologue il y a
plein de personnes que vous croisez tous
les jours qui vont en psychologue ça
veut pas dire forcément qu'elles vont
pas bien jusqu'à qu'elles aimeraient ne
pas ne pas aller bien je sais pas si
c'était compréhensible mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que voir un psychologue
ça peut être vu comme un médecin en fait
c'est un médecin mais pour le cerveau
donc c'est pas du tout un tabou vous
pouvez aller voir des psychologues juste
si vous avez quelque chose à dire
normalement je crois c'est remboursé par
la sécu si je ne dis pas de bêtises non
non
je crois que si je me trompe pas il y a
trois premières séances qui sont
remboursées avec certains psychologues
qui sont conventionnés ou pas mais c'est
plus compliqué que ça et justement c'est
peut-être aussi un système qui vous fait
réagir aussi OK et je vois justement
tu finis et après on revient vers toi
émy oui et du coup c'est vrai que je
connais beaucoup de personnes aussi qui
m'ont déjà dit non mais je sais que je
vais pas bien mais j'ai envie d'avoir
une bonne moyenne j'ai envie de réussir
ma vie et ils disent que si plus tard
enfin s'ils ont des bonnes notes
maintenant si c'est d'un à fond dans les
cours et pourront réussir plus tard le
problème c'est qu'il se il pense pas
leur santé mentale et si il se
détruisent mentalement psychologiquement
plus tard la vie ce sera elle sera
beaucoup plus difficile
Amy du coup moi je voulais réagir sur
deux choses déjà comme ces Gabin
attendez
le psychologue n'est pas remboursé il y
a que les psychiatres qui sont à moitié
remboursés donc le psychiatre c'est le
médecin qui prescrit les médicaments etc
et le psychologue c'est plus celui qui
va écoute qu'un psychologue ça coûte au
moins 40 50 euros donc c'est parfois on
a besoin d'avoir un psychologue une fois
par semaine donc ça coûte vite cher à la
fin du mois et on n'a pas forcément les
moyens mais justement c'est souvent les
[Musique]
dans les enfin j'ai vu plusieurs
témoignages etc qui disait que c'était
plus souvent dans les milieux
défavorisés que les personnes avaient
une santé mentale santé mentale plus
plus instable et justement c'est dans
les milieux défavorisés où on aurait
besoin de plus d'aide mais cette aide
n'est pas prise en compte par l'État et
la santé mentale n'est pas prise en
compte par l'État et comme dit Gabin
enfin il faut il faut la prendre en
compte il faut
je pense enfin avant je faisais passer
mes notes avant avant ma santé mentale
et ça m'a complètement détruite
j'ai complètement décroché j'ai commencé
à avoir des mauvaises notes justement et
au final ça a totalement détruit bah et
ma santé mentale et en même temps ma
scolarité et en fait j'ai tout perdu
quoi j'ai c'est difficile de remonter la
pente mais je l'ai fait grâce à des
psychologues et moi j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une mère qui me soutient et que
qui est là pour moi et qui cherche à ce
que j'aille mieux mais tout le monde n'a
pas cette chance et c'est vraiment
important en fait
[Musique]
merci Laurent on va prendre une dernière
question et puis on va passer à la
thématique d'après Rachel qu'est-ce que
tu voulais dire et du coup c'était beau
aussi pour revenir sur ce que disait
dans la globalité
si notre santé mentale si on peut pas
avoir un parcours scolaire qui suit
également ce que ça comme disait Gabin
c'est un cercle vicieux on a tendance à
s'épuiser que si mentalement on se sent
mieux on ça nous permet de mieux réussir
si on a envie etc
scolairement parce que si on sent
complètement mal on peut pas
évoluer vraiment positivement à l'école
parce que ça nous aide vraiment pas si
on n'est pas heureux d'y aller si on
sent pas bien on aura du mal à essayer
d'apprendre etc et du coup oui il
faudrait pouvoir voir plus souvent quand
on veut
un système psychologue etc mais il
faudrait qu'il y ait plus de
possibilités pour tout le monde
merci à tous de nous avoir confié vos
vis qui ce qui vous est arrivé
l'importance pour vous aussi de parler
de ce sujet on le voit vraiment avec des
témoignages très forts merci aussi
Alicia et merci vraiment à tous Nicolas
on va peut-être passer un autre sujet
oui bah déjà merci beaucoup pour vos
témoignages si c'était vraiment très
très intéressant et puis je pense que
France 3 Bourgogne c'est pour ça qu'on
fait cette émission c'est pour vous
donner la parole dans des peut-être à
d'autres endroits vous pouvez pas le
faire forcément donc on est vraiment
très très fier de vous et à votre âge je
sais pas si on aurait vraiment pu savoir
si on a vraiment le courage de faire ça
on va parler on va passer à une autre
une autre thématique qui n'a rien à voir
on va parler des jeux vidéo mais avant
d'en discuter je vous propose de vous
montrer une vidéo on a été voir
plusieurs personnes plusieurs retraités
en ville et donc du coup ils nous ont
ils nous ont donné leur opinion sur les
jeux vidéos je vous propose de les
écouter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours je sais pas si ça leur fait pas
de mal au niveau de la vue déjà j'ai
l'impression que les jeunes ils parlent
tout en abrégé
les petites lettres pour dire des mots
on comprend plus rien les jeux vidéos un
petit peu basés sur le la guerre enfin
c'est ce genre de d'activité un petit
peu néfastes je pense et ils sont
embarqués là-dedans pendant des heures
et tout d'un coup ils se disent ah tiens
je suis en retard je pense que c'est
dommage la réalité n'est pas n'est pas
la même quoi faut pas s'identifier au
héros à tuer tout ce qui bouge qui sont
toujours en train de de jouer et moi je
joue en vrai
[Musique]
j'imagine que ça a fait réagir beaucoup
de personnes ici mais on va commencer
avec toi parce que on en a parlé en
amont et je crois que t'es pas forcément
d'accord avec ce qui s'est dit dans
cette vidéo
oui en effet je trouve que c'est tous
ces préjugés là c'est un petit peu trop
facile j'ai envie de dire ce que par
exemple bah je prends l'exemple un petit
peu plus celui qui m'a fait le plus rire
une personne a dit qu'il fallait pas
confondre les jeux de guerre avec la
vraie vie qu'il fallait pas tirer sur
tout le monde dans la vraie vie à ce
compte là
on ne regarde pas de films gore par
exemple des classiques comme Scarface ça
n'aurait jamais eu lieu et pourtant je
vois jamais des gens crises qui se
filment ni rien et bizarrement quand
c'est les jeux vidéos
ça pose problème
toi aussi cette vidéo elle t'a fait
réagir
dans le sens où
on met la honte sur les jeux vidéo
plutôt que sur la responsabilité du
joueur face au jeu parce qu'on est quand
même vachement prévenus il y a quand
même des messages avant les Jeux pour
faire attention pour
pour les réactions que tous les joueurs
peuvent avoir pour et je pense que les
joueurs peuvent se responsabiliser
plutôt que de justement de se lancer à
consommer et comme disait Joris les
films on dit rien dessus alors que c'est
la même chose en fait
et tu as quelque chose à ajouter moi je
voudrais dire j'ai une passion pour la
lecture par exemple et je peux passer
des heures à lire et je sais que on va
pas vraiment cracher sur le fait que je
lis pendant des heures et que je
justement je vais m'isoler je vais
parler à personne je vais être dans mon
coin en train de lire et on reproche aux
personnes qui jouent aux jeux vidéos de
s'isoli justement alors que je trouve
que c'est pas le cas parce que il y a
des jeux multijoueurs des ils peuvent
être en ligne pour jouer et on va on va
cracher justement sur eux alors qu'il y
a d'autres
choses sur lesquelles enfin d'autres
passions qu'on a sur lesquels on va pas
cracher parce qu'elles sont plus
artistiques plus elles vont plus faire
travailler le mental entre guillemets et
je trouve que c'est vraiment un peu
débile
merci Gabin
si quelqu'un peut lui donner micro ah
bah vas-y vas-y je voulais dire pour
préparer ce débat j'ai bah fait débat
moi-même avec des amis qui jouent
énormément parce que je connais pas
vraiment ce sujet et j'ai été étonné
parce que
ils apprennent énormément de choses ils
échangent avec énormément de personnes
ils apprennent toutes sortes de choses
ils savent ils sont
diversifiés sur toutes sortes de sujets
et donc moi-même qui avait pas vraiment
des a priori mais qui connaissaient pas
vraiment je trouve que
ce côté jeux de vidéo permet de
développer plusieurs choses qui sont pas
sous pas spécialement néfastes et au
contraire qui sont positifs
alors j'ai plusieurs choses à dire sur
le sujet parce que c'est un sujet qui me
tient qui me tient très à coeur
particulièrement parce que j'ai comment
j'habite très loin de mon meilleur ami
Jules ici on habite à plus de 45 minutes
d'écart et on pouvait pas passer du
temps ensemble souvent et les jeux
vidéos ça nous permet de nous rapprocher
tous les tous les week-ends
avec d'autres amis à nous on a rencontré
des amis qui habitent sur Paris dans
même des amis à nous qui habitent dans
d'autres pays qui ne parlent pas notre
langue ça a permis de travailler notre
anglais notre prononciation de
comprendre différents accents des choses
comme ça et après il y a certains jeux
vidéo comme par les Rachel qui va qui
vont comment tu vas améliorer nos
compétences on peut parler par exemple
du premier exemple du contre-exemple que
donne des personnes qui ne sont pas en
connaissance les jeux vidéo de guerre et
ben en fait ça va augmenter beaucoup les
réflexes des personnes ça va leur
permettre d'avoir des meilleurs réflexes
beaucoup plus de concentration ce que
mine de rien la plupart des jeux
multijoueurs tout ça ça va être des jeux
où il y a besoin de beaucoup de
concentration de communication des
choses qui sont beaucoup demander dans
le monde du travail et qui comme ça on
peut pas se rendre compte forcément que
c'est un lien entre le monde du travail
et un jeu vidéo type Call of Duty alors
qu'en fait c'est des c'est des choses
qui peuvent nous adapter à communiquer
avec des gens et puis à mieux nous
concentrer on peut parler aussi elles
ont de minecraft c'est un jeu de
construction qui nous permet de
d'augmenter notre créativité de de
partager des choses avec nos amis de
créer des monuments je sais par exemple
qui a une communauté française il me
semble qu'elle est française qui recréer
la planète en entière
c'est vraiment des ambitions comme ça
qui rapprochent des gens
aussi on peut avoir les jeux comme
Assassin's Creed qui sont des jeux
qui vont être développés par les studios
Ubisoft et ils vont être en
collaboration directe avec des
historiens et il y a eu plein de saga
Assassin's Creed qui ont été par exemple
sur la Grèce antique sur la Rome sur la
l'Egypte sur le la période des Vikings
sur
sur l'air victorienne sur la Révolution
française plein de choses comme ça et
c'est fait avec des historiens et tout
est enfin c'est des reproductions très
très réel en fait c'est ce qui s'est
passé ça reprend des certains contextes
historiques et qui par exemple moi j'y
peux prendre beaucoup de choses en
jouant à des Assassin's Creed et tout ça
voilà et aussi je pense Rachel et
voulait dire quelque chose là dessus
qui voulait parler
attends je vais juste rebondir sur ce
que j'avais envie de dire il faut pas
oublier que derrière jeux vidéo il y
aura toujours une histoire dont ce qu'on
appelle un Laure et que c'est pas
forcément un jeu de guerre par exemple
via Zelda où ça va être une aventure
dans un monde un peu fantaisie ou plein
d'autres jeux qui vont être des open
world on peut découvrir un nouveau monde
et que du coup ça peut être comparé à un
livre ou une série un film puisqu'on
suit une histoire en même temps et que
c'est pas forcément juste tuer des gens
j'avais pas compris
pour les rencontres bah j'ai un exemple
par exemple il y a un événement qui a
lieu toutes les années entre septembre
octobre qui s'appelle le the event il a
été créé par zeratoR et dash qui sont
des créateurs de contenu qu'on appelle
des streamers ça réunit plusieurs
streamers francophones
et ils vont jouer à des jeux vidéo et du
coup bah faire des vidéos en direct pour
des associations de caricatives la
première édition elle a eu lieu en 2016
c'était pour l'association
parce que je l'ai bien prononcé
où ils ont récolté 170000 euros au
départ il y avait 16 participants et bah
la dernière qui a eu lieu en 2022
c'était contre la Ligue de Protection
d'oiseaux ils ont gagné 10 millions
10 millions
1042 126000 euros il y avait 57
participants
donc on voit que ça aussi un impact
important sur dans le monde associatif
et Rachel voilà je reviens vers toi
cette fois c'est à ton tour
aussi sur Gabin ou pour prendre
l'exemple de mon grand frère qui a
toujours joué au jeu vidéo qui va
connaître plus de un peu plus d'histoire
sur tout ce qui s'est passé avant
contrairement à moi qui aurait tendance
à un peu plus réviser par rapport à lui
et tout ça il a appris grâce à ce jeu ou
du coup il a développé
toute une culture historique grâce à ça
il y a une petite question dans le
public aussi
j'aimerais revenir aussi sur le module
qu'on a vu dans le sens où les personnes
présentes avaient dit que ça abimait
beaucoup les yeux et tout ça pas
forcément enfin oui mais dans le sens où
elles sont assez culottées parce que
les trois quarts des gens qui jouent aux
jeux vidéos le jeu sur
un écran TV donc comme quand vous par
exemple vous regardez la télévision donc
oui on est à peu près la même distance
n'est pas collé non plus sur nos écrans
à 2 cm donc on s'abîme autant les yeux
que vous
on n'avait pas fier et vous devrez pas
être non plus mais voilà merci Joris au
Bury dans le public ça fait aussi réagir
je crois ouais je suis avec Carl juste
là il a une petite question alors car
dis-moi qu'est-ce que tu veux en fait
moi c'est pas réellement une question
c'est plus une affirmation pour les gens
de notre âge je tiens à dire que quand
même à l'âge de 15 16 17 ans depuis
petit enfin surtout à notre avec notre
génération on baigne dans les jeux vidéo
et à l'heure actuelle je pense que les
jeux vidéo c'est des espaces de partage
au sein de la famille par exemple moi
j'ai un grand frère depuis qu'on est
petit on partage des moments mais
incroyables sur les jeux vidéos c'est
des moments de partage entre génération
il y a pas que ça par exemple il y a des
événements des grands événements tels
que des concours sur certains jeux vidéo
qui réunissent les plus jeunes comme les
plus vieux la créativité comme le dit
Gabin tout à l'heure sur Minecraft il y
a beaucoup d'enfants qui par manque de
moyens ou par exemple quand on a pas de
frère et sœur c'est difficile de pouvoir
s'exprimer avec des personnes de notre
âge dans Minecraft avec des amis ça
permet de mettre en application notre
imagination tout simplement et je pense
que à l'heure actuelle les jeux vidéo
prennent une place assez importante pour
nous
et on le voit aussi sur le chat il y a
beaucoup de gens qui réagissent
là-dessus en se disant que les jeux
vidéo c'est aussi un moyen pour eux de
s'échapper d'échapper à leurs problèmes
qu'est-ce que vous en dites vous c'est
aussi pour ça que que vous jouez
justement je suis content en parler on
avait parlé du fait que que tout à
l'heure sur la santé mentale il y avait
des personnes que j'ai pas se confier
bah justement on peut je connais plein
de gens qui sont allés justement sur les
jeux vidéo pour pouvoir trouver un
exutoire pour pouvoir partager avec
d'autres gens qui ne connaissent pas
forcément des problèmes qui est qu'ils
ont dans la vie de tous les jours
pouvoir se sentir écouter avoir des amis
qui n'ont pas forcément dans la vraie
vie on oublie souvent que les jeux vidéo
c'est au-delà du simple jeu on n'est pas
tout seul enfermé comme comme des gnomes
dans notre chambre on est souvent avec
des amis des gens qui nous comprennent
des personnes qui ont fait confiance
qu'on aime parler donc certains parents
et si vous pensez que vos enfants vous
parlent pas c'est sûrement le cas mais
quand vous les entendez rire dans votre
chambre dites-vous que c'est avec des
personnes à qui tiennent beaucoup et à
qui pars seulement de leurs problèmes et
ces personnes là sont les personnes
sûrement qui sont très importantes pour
eux donc les disputés parce qu'ils
jouent les privés ça va leur faire
intérieurement une comment on dit ils
vont sentir coupable de de jouer alors
que ça leur permet de sentir mieux pour
la plupart et ben justement en parlant
des parents apparemment selon un sondage
40% des enfants jouent sans l'accord de
leurs parents moi j'ai une question à
vous poser à vous poser pardon est-ce
que vous pensez que avec tous les jeux
et certains jeux sont quand même assez
violents on devrait pas avoir un
contrôle parental plus important
c'est vrai que le contrôle parental je
suis tout à fait d'accord dessus il y a
des il y a des jeux qui sont accessibles
trop enfin qui sont trop facilement
accessibles pour des pour des enfants
qui sont en bas âge mais aussi je
connais par exemple j'ai ma soeur qui a
2 ans qui a deux enfants et leur laisse
déjà le téléphone des jeux vidéo alors
que le plus jeune à peine 5 ans il avait
déjà 3 ans et il jouait déjà il savait à
peine il savait à peine parlé qu'il
savait qu'il était déjà sur une console
il savait même pas comment ça
fonctionnait et la mer le laisser le
laisser jouer comme ça donc il y a
certains parents aussi qui sont pas très
responsables c'est pas forcément tout le
temps la faute des enfants aussi
beaucoup d'enfants qui vont qui vont
jouer parce que leur camarades jouent et
c'est vrai que les parents devraient
avoir un certain contrôle mais quand
même ce se rendre compte que le contrôle
ne va pas jusqu'au de la des 13 14 15
ans après faut quand même laisser son
enfant pouvoir jouer à des jeux je pense
qu'à 15 ans une limite de 18 ans et
assez exagéré certains jeux de guerre à
15 ans c'est ce que là on sait ce qu'est
la guerre et on sait ce qu'on veut qu'on
ne doit pas faire et car jeux vidéo est
fictif mais c'est vrai que pour certains
enfants c'est bien de leur interdire de
jouer à certains types de jeux violents
ou alors avoir une consommation plus
raisonnable de jeu parce que on peut
parler aussi des addictions je sais pas
si quelqu'un a quelque chose à dire sur
les addictions ici pas pour le jeu vidéo
je vais en parler alors si
certaines personnes vont souvent dire
qu'on a dicte aux jeux vidéos mais ça va
être comme toute addiction tout peut
être une addiction on peut dire que les
jeux vidéos c'est ces poisons mais comme
par hasses disait rien n'est poison tout
est poison c'est la dose qui fait poison
et
à quelqu'un qui va beaucoup jouer aux
jeux vidéos par exemple moi-même je peux
parler j'ai été j'ai une addiction aux
jeux vidéo je m'en suis rendu compte et
j'ai fini par par arrêter complètement
j'ai coupé mon ordinateur et là je l'ai
toujours pas ça va faire bientôt un mois
et je vais sûrement le reprendre pour
les vacances et je maintenant j'ai été
décevrai entre guillemets on pourrait
dire des jeux vidéo et c'est une force
que certaines personnes peut-être qui
nous écoutaient qui sont addict à
l'alcool à la drogue voire à la
cigarette et qui n'arrive pas à arrêter
alors que les jeux vidéo beaucoup plus
de personnes de notre âge sont
conscientes qui peuvent être addictes et
arrêtez tout simplement l'addiction
c'est comme tout vous êtes peuvent vous
pouvez être addict à n'importe quoi et
je trouve ça des fois un peu culotté que
des parents disent à leurs enfants tu
vas être addict aux jeux vidéo tu joues
tout le temps alors que lui il ressent
une vraie partie de plaisir il apprend
des choses et il a aucune enfin quelque
chose de néfaste sur sa santé alors que
les parents vont fumer ça leur apporte
rien concrètement donc c'est un petit
peu culotté il faut et c'est un modèle
parental en fait si vous dites à votre
enfant qui joue trop et qui va devenir
addict essayer d'arrêter certaines
addictions que vous avez propres à vous
de jeux vidéo on peut peut-être aussi
parler des réseaux sociaux
j'imagine que vous aussi vous vous avez
vu des clichés en tout cas des adultes
qui tiennent des clichés sur sur vous et
votre utilisation de ces réseaux Rachel
tu veux commencer j'ai un avis un peu
mitigé ce que à la fois je trouve ça
bien et en même temps j'aime moins
j'aime un peu moins je sais que j'étais
quand même beaucoup dessus ce qu'on peut
trouver des des activités vraiment qui
nous aident on peut ça apprendre de
nombreuses choses d'une façon plus
pédagogique et plus simple de façon que
ce soit plus compréhensible pour nous
mais à la fois par les réseaux sociaux
sont faits pour qu'on passe beaucoup de
temps dessus on a tendance à plus
décrocher des choses importantes pour
passer du temps sur des choses qui sont
peut-être un peu moins importantes mais
à la fois faut penser que dessus il y a
des choses qui sont vraiment bien et qui
nous aident à progresser sur certains
éléments
tu veux répondre
moi je dirais que les réseaux sociaux
c'est comme Rachel bien et pas bien mais
je suis plus pour les réseaux sociaux
parce que enfin personnellement
j'utilise les réseaux sociaux pour
m'informer plutôt que de regarder par
exemple les informations à la télé comme
la plupart des gens je dirais les
personnes plus âgées moi je regarde les
informations sur Instagram ou sur Tik
Tok et je trouve ça plus ludique plus
plus fun et je préfère largement
et
je trouve que les réseaux sociaux c'est
à quelque chose de réconfortant parce
que
je suis beaucoup sur Tik Tok par exemple
et je sais que je vais voir des
personnes qui vont exprimer soit leur
mal-être soit leur bonheur et ça va
ça va faire en sorte par exemple quand
ils expriment leur mal-être que je me
sente moins seule et je sais que sur les
réseaux sociaux j'ai pu rencontrer
beaucoup de personnes et j'ai pu
discuter avec beaucoup de personnes et
ça permet de d'avoir un entourage plus
large
Achille je vois que tu prends des notes
tu veux rebondir dessus j'essaye de rien
oublier sur ce que je veux dire déjà je
suis complètement d'accord avec Rachel
et Amy les réseaux sociaux je suis pas
contre c'est juste que à mon avis on les
utilise très mal et ils sont faits pour
être addictif de toute façon et Tik Tok
je l’impression que c'est le meilleur
exemple à donner pour la diction c'est à
dire que c'est le seul réseau sociaux
qui te dit prends une pause sur sa page
genre littéralement Tik Tok post des
trucs sur son compte TikTok pour nous
dire ferme l'application
ça montre qu'ils ont au moins conscience
que il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
addicts aussi les informations sur les
réseaux sociaux comme disait ami
j'aimerais rassurer les gens qui
connaissent pas trop il y a pas mal de
chaînes d'infos qui sont fiables sur les
réseaux sociaux contrairement à ce qu'on
pense il y a pas que des fake news bien
sûr qu'il y en a il y en a pas il y a
pas que ça par exemple moi j'ai pas ni
les moyens ni l'envie d'avoir la télé ou
le journal ou quoi et j'ai pas le temps
de lire le journal de toute façon donc
avoir les actualités du jour résumé en
60 secondes par Hugo descript ça
m'arrange bien en fait parce que ça
m'évite d'être complètement déconnecté
de la réalité comme je l'étais à une
époque et je trouve qu'il y a pas mal de
réseau qui sont vachement bien parce que
ils nous permettent de d'exprimer notre
créativité à travers des postes et de
nous faire connaître si on veut être si
on est artiste freelance ce genre de
choses donc il y a vraiment une partie
très positive et une partie très
addictive donc négative
moi je voudrais peut-être revenir sur
Tik Tok parce que ça se trouve il y a
des gens qui nous regardent et qui
savent pas forcément ce que c'est que
c'est un réseau social où on peut
regarder des courtes vidéos qui vont
maintenant jusqu'à 3 minutes je crois
même plus 10 minutes et du coup c'est
très addictif parce que souvent bah on
soigne du coup on regarde on regarde les
vidéos et comme elles sont courtes en
regardant plus et du coup bah on reste
longtemps sur ce réseau
merci Gabin et justement les réseaux
sociaux c'est un endroit où il peut
avoir du partage par exemple comme on
reprend Tik Tok Tik Tok ou des gens vont
poster leur vie leur quotidien leur
passion des gens qui vont parler des
instruments de musique ils aiment jouer
de leur art de ce qu'ils apprennent il y
a beaucoup de de professeurs qui sont
sur Tik Tok et leurs courses sont super
intéressants ils vont expliquer d'une
manière que nous qui nous intéresse
beaucoup plus avec des illustrations des
choses qui beaucoup plus nous parler et
je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
vont réviser sur Tik Tok qui vont
réviser sur d'autres réseaux sociaux ou
des professeurs eux-mêmes vont poster
des choses pour aider les élèves et
aussi les réseaux sociaux faut pas
oublier que c'est un endroit de partage
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui vous
pouvez voir votre votre enfant votre
garçon votre fille tout ça qui sont sur
qui sont sur leur téléphone à part la
des amis mais c'est pour leur permettre
de se rapprocher vous parler bien de
certains adultes à vos copains sur
facebook tout ça c'est permettre de
moyens de rester rassurer de voir des
photos de la famille tout ça on fait
pareil sur les réseaux sociaux sur
snapchat sur Instagram ça on parle avec
nos amis on partage des trucs rigolos
des fois on s'envoie les devoirs je sais
que exemple nous de notre classe on a on
a notre groupe d'achlp on a des groupes
pour le théâtre on a des groupes pour
deux classes tout simplement on a des
groupes pour un peu tout on
parle des devoirs et tout ça et on fait
on fait plein de choses en rapport
scolairement donc c'est faut pas enfin
garder les réseaux sociaux à quelque
chose d'inutile c'est on a beaucoup
utilisé ça sur plein de domaines
différents merci mais Wen quelque chose
de personnel je crois un outil ben moi
j'ai habité Tahiti et j'ai de la famille
ici et ben j'ai pu grâce aux réseaux
sociaux leur partager mes moments les
faire voyager avec moi parce que
forcément ils avaient pas les moyens et
grâce enfin grâce aux réseaux sociaux
j'ai pu leur envoyer des photos
d'où j'habitais de la mer de plein de
bonnes choses et ça le enfin
il rêvait de ça et voilà comme quoi
c'est un outil ben très enfin pour moi
il est important parce que
je suis ici avec mon père et j'ai ma
mère qui est qui est restée là-bas et
ben je lui envoie des photos d'ici pour
qu'il y a des clous avec pardon qu'elle
découvre la France voilà
ça lui permet de voyager avec toi avec
moi voilà on a souvent un sondage il y a
alors selon un sondage j'ai retrouvé
voilà selon un sondage il y a une il y a
les jeunes passent une heure 46 de leur
temps par jour sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que vous trouvez que ce chiffre
enfin est-ce que ça vous choque un peu
ou est-ce que pour vous c'est normal
est-ce que vous êtes trop sur les
réseaux sociaux
à préciser que c'est beaucoup plus que
1h46 pour la plupart des personnes ici
donc voilà 1h46 si vous pensez que
c'était beaucoup je suis désolé de vous
décevoir mais c'est encore beaucoup plus
que ça certaines personnes ça peut même
aller jusqu'à 4 5 heures 6h le week-end
rester sur les réseaux mais ça va être
ça va être des réseaux par exemple
YouTube on va on va prendre des trucs ou
je sais que par exemple des fois sur les
réseaux j'adore les regarder des trucs
pour me renseigner donc pensez pas que
non plus même s'il y a 1h43 c'est 1h43
regarder des bêtises je veux dire un
gros mot d'arrêter de regarder des
bêtises et puis de parler à à nos amis
on essaie de se renseigner tout ça
d'apprendre des choses et tout c'est
aussi un moyen ludique pour nous
d'apprendre beaucoup de choses
quelqu'un d'autre oui je sais qu'avant
les contrôles
ce le nombre d'heures augmentait ce que
souvent on trouve des vidéos qui nous
rappellent le cours un peu plus
simplement plus rapidement et du coup
oui ça passe plus de temps mais à la
fois j'ai désinstallé Instagram parce
que j'ai vu que je passais vraiment du
temps et que j'ai pris conscience que
parfois c'était vraiment
inutile pourquoi j'étais dessus donc
j'ai préféré le désinstaller pour être
sûr parce que je peux toujours trouver
des vidéos pour m'aider à scolairement
autre part mais à la fois j'ai du coup
supprimer tout ce qui était possible de
me disperser inutilement
inutilement du coup c'est pour je trouve
ça préférable pour moi comme ça je suis
sûr que tout ce qui est chose inutile je
les ai enlevés et je peux garder tout ce
qui est utile réellement pour que ce
soit parler avec des amis ou juste
apprendre pour mes cours
pour moi je suis d'accord avec Gabin le
chiffre est clairement beaucoup plus
élevé et bien sûr que on va beaucoup
trop sur les réseaux sociaux bien sûr
que bon on est la plupart d'entre nous
sont addict on peut clairement le dire
mais oui on les utilise mal mais il y a
certains moments aussi où oui comme on a
déjà dit ça nous permet de réviser tout
ça
je pense que on n'est pas tout tout beau
non plus on a clairement des défauts on
peut clairement réduire mais de là
prendre je sais pas beaucoup de
réflexion par exemple sur ça je trouve
que c'est clairement pas nécessaire
alors juste faire une petite précision
quand on part d'une heure 46 c'est pas
que les jeunes je me suis trompé c'est
la population française entière donc il
y a peut-être les personnes un peu plus
âgées que vous qui sont aussi sur les
réseaux et peut-être qu'elles y sont un
peu moins donc si jamais on prend que
les jeunes c'est sans doute comme vous
le dites un petit peu plus un petit peu
plus conséquent en termes de temps Joris
parlait d'addiction c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait considérer ça comme une
addiction mais faut faut pas dire une
addition réseaux sociaux et plutôt aux
choses qu'on peut y trouver certaines
personnes vont être addict aux réseaux
sociaux justement par rapport à parler à
des personnes d'autres qui vont être
addicts à au bien-être que ça peut leur
apporter il y a certains créateurs de
contenu beaucoup de youtubeurs on
pourrait parler de type Squeezie ou
enquête studio qui nous permettent de
faire des vidéos qui vont nous faire
rigoler qui vont nous permettre de nous
sentir bien qui vont qui vont nous
rassurer nous permettre après une
journée de cours qui était vraiment très
intense de pouvoir se reposer de rigoler
de passer un bon moment ça c'est super
cool et beaucoup de gens comme ça aussi
il y en a qui vont être addict au fait
d'avoir de la des connaissances des de
recevoir plein de connaissances
d'apprendre des choses plus ludiquement
que que dans les cours parce que je
connais certaines personnes qui
n'apprennent rien à l'école ça les
ennuie beaucoup et alors que quand il
rentre chez eux ils adorent apprendre
plein de choses sur internet des choses
qui les intéressent eux et ça va être
une addiction pas aux réseaux sociaux
mais l'addiction au sujet qui les
intéresse où ils vont pouvoir se
renseigner sur les réseaux sociaux
et même je voulais revenir au fait que
qu'on passe beaucoup plus beaucoup
beaucoup
de temps dessus c'est faut savoir
qu'elle est les applications sont
intelligentes tu peux liker une vidéo et
à chaque fois tu le like la même fin le
même genre de vidéo et à chaque fois ils
vont te le même ils vont te remettre le
même contenu ce qui fait que tu vas
jamais dans lacets et continuer à rester
dessus et du coup tu vas pas voilà merci
à tous je vous propose que maintenant on
passe au sujet d'après le sujet qu'on va
évoquer maintenant c'est celui de la
politique est-ce que les jeunes s'y
intéressent ou pas vous allez pouvoir le
voir maintenant
et pour cela on va donc démarrer avec un
module vidéo pour poser le regarder
alors juste avant ça je crois qu'il y a
Aubry qui a une petite question dans le
château de bruit tout à fait alors on
revient à ce sujet des réseaux sociaux
il y a Lucie qui nous dit que avec les
jeux vidéo les réseaux sociaux on a
tendance à avoir peut-être une
dégradation des des relations c'est à
dire qu'on sort moi on se renferme un
peu plus sur soi-même et que justement
les jeux vidéo et les réseaux sociaux ça
permet d'avoir des relations avec des
gens un peu plus loin avec des gens on
s'entend plus facilement parce que on
côtoie des personnes avec qui on pense
pareil est-ce que vous vous pensez que
justement les réseaux sociaux les jeux
vidéo c'est un peu le futur des
relations
je te propose de rejoindre le public une
question dans le public en plus une
réponse même
pas trop une question mais plus une
réaction
donc par rapport à ce que Aubry c'est ça
a dit moi je sais que ben j'ai déménagé
donc
j'y habité au Gabon avant donc c'est en
Afrique c'est très loin 6000 km mais par
exemple les réseaux sociaux ou les jeux
vidéo ça permet donc de rapprocher de
mes anciens amis ou alors de personnes
qu'on peut plus côtoyer et c'est le cas
pour beaucoup de personnes ici parce que
bah dans la vie on a amené à bouger et
pouvoir profiter de ces moments là sans
forcément être à côté de ces personnes
là bah les réseaux sociaux ou les jeux
vidéo nous permettent de le faire et je
pense que c'est plutôt une bonne chose
pour ça
et vous en pensez quoi vous
je suis d'accord que les réseaux sociaux
de façon de même dans le non réseau
sociaux c'est pour apporter une cohésion
sociale entre chaque personne donc pour
moi je pense c'est peut-être c'est
sûrement l'avenir de de la communication
tout ça c'est vrai que d'avoir des
communications il y a des gens qui sont
à l'école tout ça on peut avoir des amis
à l'école mais il y a à peu près il y a
des certaines personnes qui sont
déscolarisées qui ne peuvent pas aller à
l'école tout simplement
à cause de certains handicaps précarité
ou des choses comme ça et qui permet de
les réseaux sociaux ça leur permet de
rencontrer des personnes parce que c'est
vraiment pas facile mais vous vous
pouvez vous en rendre compte chez vous
d'aller voir quelqu'un dans la rue et de
lui demander hey salut est-ce que tu es
de mon pote tu vois c'est pas facile
comme ça donc c'est sûr que sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est plus facile de
faire des rencontres même sur les jeux
vidéos de partager des choses et c'est
justement des choses qui nous
intéressent quoi
j'ai réussi à désinstaller insta mais ce
qui est compliqué ce que c'était
là-dessus où je pouvais échanger avec
des amis qui sont vraiment très loin
contrairement je pourrais pas le
désinstaller snap parce que c'est
essentiellement des des conversations
mais c'est compliqué de se dire qu'on
pourrait plus parler à certaines
personnes j'avais ma cousine quitte à
Tahiti je c'est compliqué de l'avoir
réellement c'est cool d'écrire des
lettres mais ça c'est moins facile j'ai
des amis qui sont un peu partout donc
oui à la fois c'est beaucoup plus simple
les réseaux pour échanger et garder
contact avec des amis proches ou même du
coup en pour s'en faire des nouveaux
merci Rachel bon ben là je propose qu'on
passe vraiment au sujet sur la politique
je me suis un peu emballé tout à l'heure
pour ça moi ma première question ça va
être est-ce que vous en tant que jeune
lycéen vous vous sentez concerné par la
politique et n'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à
revenir sur ce qui se passe aussi dans
l'actualité en ce moment je pense que
certains ont sans doute des choses à
dire Achille d'ailleurs alors oui
personnellement je suis extrêmement
concernée par la politique d'un côté on
m'a baigné dedans très jeunes
parce que tout simplement mes parents
n'étaient pas du tout d'accord avec les
opinions politiques de la famille
généraux donc on avait vraiment le parti
opposé enfin ils avaient vraiment le
parti opposé et je les ai rejoint par la
suite quand j'ai pu me faire une idée
moi-même de ce qu'était la politique
parce qu'en revanche ils m'ont jamais
influencé mais c'est vrai que maintenant
que j'ai une petite idée de ce que c'est
la politique ça m'intéresse énormément
et on a beaucoup beaucoup entendu parler
notamment avec le 49-3 la réforme des
retraites tout ça je pense que on vous
en a pas mal bassiné les oreilles à vous
aussi dans notre côté c'est très
important
on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de gens dans
la rue j'ai plus les nombres précis des
manifs mais c'était des nombres assez
conséquent quand même et notamment la
jeunesse la phrase a été bronzée la
jeunesse à la rue et ça inquiétait le
gouvernement d'ailleurs
moi par exemple je me sens concernée par
la politique mais ça m'intéresse pas du
tout parce que bah déjà je comprends pas
tout à mon âge je trouve que c'est
beaucoup du bourrage de crâne donc
j'aimerais bah je me sens concerner
parce que je sais que bientôt je vais
devoir voter mais je comprends pas tout
du coup bah ça m'intéresse pas
personnellement je me trompe je me sens
très concernée par la politique parce
que comme je l'ai dit plusieurs fois ça
constitue comme une autre avenir mais je
trouve que malheureusement on n'est pas
assez informé on n'est pas assez en tant
que jeune n'est pas assez inclus dans la
politique on nous dit un truc du genre
tu es trop jeune pour te faire un avis
tu es trop jeune pour réfléchir alors
que c'est quand même dans pas longtemps
qu'on doit dire qu'on devait réfléchir
on a tous donc justement dans pas
longtemps et
on est tous très concernés parce que
c'est quand même notre avenir notamment
la réforme des retraites justement
très bien Rachel tu voulais ajouter
quelque chose oui c'était par rapport
aussi ce que disait les filles je trouve
que c'est quand même assez important
comme sujet mais c'est un truc que je
déteste parce que on a on a des
informations on sait jamais si c'est
réellement vrai apprendre à te prendre
que c'est faux il y a ceci il y a cela
on sait jamais concret on en parle c'est
assez vaste il y a on pourrait aimer pas
aimer mais soutenir un peu
un politicien sauf que dans leur partie
il y a toujours quelque chose qui nous
déplaît on nous demande de choisir entre
plusieurs personnes sauf que à chaque
fois on est obligé de choisir quelque
chose qu'on n'aime pas ou un autre truc
qu'on n'aime pas non plus si je trouve
que c'est vraiment compliqué pour ce que
c'est
quelque chose je crois
moi je trouve que voter c'est un droit
et un devoir en même temps parce que moi
je me mets à la place de d'autres
personnes qui dans leur propre pays ne
peuvent pas voter comme nous nous avons
la chance de lire celui qui qui
ferait en sorte que son pays va bien qui
voilà par exemple en Russie ou ça va
faire des
ânes enfin plus tu une dizaine d'années
que Poutine est toujours au pouvoir et
que malheureusement ils ont enfin c'est
ils ont le droit de voter mais on sait
très bien que les votes ne sont pas pris
en compte que la vie des des habitants
n'est pas pris en compte
d'accord avec toi j'ai la même vision je
suis d'accord que bon on peut pas forcer
les gens à les voter il y a plein de
gens qui s'abstiennent maintenant
d'aller voter qui ne se sentent plus
concernés mais je suis d'accord que en
France on a la chance de pouvoir voter
de donner de donner notre avis et je
trouve que c'est une chose très
importante de pouvoir aller voter de
s'exprimer sur sur ces sujets là même si
on sent pas concerné c'est vrai qu'en se
mettant la place de pays qui ne peuvent
pas le faire c'est vrai que ça ça change
tout ça donne Alicia tu as quelque chose
à jeter moi pour compléter du coup ce
que Mewen et Gabin disait
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait 52,5% de
personnes entre 18 et 24 ans qui
votaient et je voulais dire que c'était
très peu sachant que il y a certains
pays du coup qui n'ont pas le droit de
voter
moi je suis d'accord on a le enfin c'est
une chance d'avoir le droit de voter
mais je trouve que les partis politiques
actuelles
enfin c'est un peu n'importe quoi je
suis pas très bonne en politique parce
que ça m'intéresse pas vraiment mais je
sais que j'entends beaucoup mes parents
parler de politique c'est vraiment le
sujet principal à la maison et quand
j'entends ce qu'ils disent et que
j'essaye de me faire mon propre avis sur
certaines choses je me dis mais en fait
tous les partis politiques ont quelque
chose que j'aime bien et à certains
partis politiques que j'aime plus que
d'autres mais il y aura toujours quelque
chose qui va pas en fait quelque chose
qui se sera contre nos valeurs et du
coup c'est dur parce que parfois c'est
vraiment contre nos principes et c'est
vraiment dur de choisir et je trouve que
en tant que jeune on peut avoir du mal à
se faire notre propre avis aussi
je trouve justement que comme on disait
il y a pas si longtemps que le nombre
d'abstentions devrait être quelque chose
d'alarmement pour les partis politiques
et que je trouve que les hommes
politiques actuellement enfin les
personnes politiques sont très hors de
la réalité ils sont très dans leur monde
ils sont plus du tout proches du peuple
et
comment dire ils ont plus cette notion
de de la vie des gens de en fait ils ont
leur avis et c'est tout
moi je voulais revenir à la à la
question de base bien sûr que je me sens
concerné parce que de toute façon dans
pas longtemps j'irai voter moi aussi
mais je trouve que c'est un monde la
politique qui manque un peu d'honnêteté
où il y a beaucoup d'hypocrisie je
trouve ce que on sait jamais vraiment
qui dit la vérité qui va faire ce qu'il
dit vraiment et on sent des fois que
même si il promettent des choses c'est
juste pour avoir notre vote et ses
promesses sont pas forcément tenues
je suis d'accord avec avec Laurane et
Joris c'est vrai que dans que on n'a pas
l'impression en rejoignant Lorraine que
certains politiques se sentent proches
de nous et en jeans Joris wiki disent
pas tout le temps de vérité parce que le
système politique actuel ça va être de
l'avoir d'avoir le plus de voix possible
et c'est le but justement mais en dépit
de la vérité et des certains veulent se
sentir proche du peuple et vont raconter
des mensonges ou dire des choses qui les
intéressent pas du tout par exemple je
vais prendre l'exemple de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui va beaucoup parler essayer
de se faire sentir proche des jeunes
tout ça alors honnêtement c'est très
bien qui s'en fout totalement il est il
parle des pauvres il est né dans la
richesse il n'a jamais travaillé de sa
vie et il va et c'est la démagogie plus
récente et je trouve justement que ce
politicien n'a rien à faire en fait il
est juste là pour parler se faire élire
et puis faire et puis se sentir se
sentir aimé et avoir les caméras sur lui
autrement je pense que s'il était vu il
aurait aucun plan enfin à aucun plan
politique voilà alors c'est ton avis un
Gabin bien sûr ça n'engage que toi c'est
mon avis politique c'est pas aussi à
répondre si vous voulez répondre à Gabin
on peut vous passer un micro aussi mais
ouais d'abord ben moi je trouve que si
les parties trouver une entente juste
pour gouverner parce que chaque mine de
rien chaque partie a de très bonnes
idées mais c'est juste qu'ils
s'entendent pas et que il devrait
enfin il devrait il devrait mettre tous
leurs idées en commun et comme ça
peut-être que ça amènera une
mieux à une bonne gestion du
gouvernement ainsi que de la nation
merci Mewen peut-être que ce que Gabin a
dit a fait réagir aussi dans le chat ou
d'autres propos obéis comment ça se
passe tout à fait réagir alors on a un
certain JT sur le chat qui nous dit
système scolaire a changé problème de
santé mentale insuffisamment prise en
charge réseaux sociaux addictif qui
viennent pas les des relations sociales
insatisfaisantes tous les problèmes que
vous avez évoqués en somme et si les
jeunes se posaient le problème de
changer la société qui génère tout ça
comment on fait pour pour changer ça
ouf c'est une très vaste
qui a envie de se lancer là-dedans là
maintenant
sur le Gabon alors
honnêtement je trouve déjà on commence à
faire quelque chose rien qu'en faisant
ce débat ici sur la chaîne Youtube de
France 3 Bourgogne Franche-Comté ça nous
compte beaucoup enfin ça compte beaucoup
pour nous de pouvoir donner notre avis
de pouvoir s'exprimer mais je trouve
qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait attendre
une échelle plus grosse aller voir des
chaînes d'information peut-être plus
importantes au cœur de tous les Français
et de ce de se mobiliser chaque jeune si
j'en avais les moins si j'étais dans la
capitale j'aimerais bien par exemple
pouvoir m'exprimer plus ouvertement bon
je sais que j'ai des avis qui sont pas
du tout commun à tout le monde mais au
moins parler sur les avis que les gens
sont du même avis que moi sur la sur
comme a dit oberhy toutes les choses
qu'on a dit comme le système scolaire la
santé mentale et tout ça justement c'est
des choses que l'État devrait prendre en
compte plus nous écouter et ça serait
peut-être pas mal que que un jeune de
notre âge ou un peu plus âgé qui sont
concernés aussi à y voir un par exemple
notre Président Monsieur Macron s'il
nous écoute ça serait enfin si ça
faisait à ses oreilles ça serait super
cool
qui prennent ces en considération qui
essaie de revoir le système éducatif
parce que on en parle beaucoup mais
c'est très peu écouté et ça ferait
changer beaucoup de choses dans la
France et on parle beaucoup qu'on fait
c'est une course
comment dire ça non vulgairement qui
aimerait enfin qui veut avoir la plus
fin se sentir oui voilà entre chaque
pays pour avoir la meilleure éducation
et justement je pense à rajouter des
heures à rajouter des devoirs rajouter
tout plein de choses ça fait juste
endommager le système éducatif donc si
Monsieur Macron vous entendez un jour ça
serait bien justement de réduire les
augmenter tout le temps et ça
augmenterait peut-être les résultats et
aussi sur la santé mentale de prendre
tout ça en charge faire en sorte qu'il y
ait des psychologues beaucoup plus
accessible et toutes ces choses là et
j'espère que juste à notre petite
échelle on essaiera de changer les
choses merci on vous demandera à la fin
de cette émission un peu quel conseil
vous donner aux adultes on reviendra
là-dessus et puis j'espère vous sortir
un bon catalogue pour les plus âgés
Achille tu voulais réagir aussi alors
j'aimerais réagir parce que c'est
vraiment
je pense que ce commentaire était
bienveillant mais c'est facile de dire
que les jeunes vous faites rien pour
changer ce dont vous vous peignez si on
nous écoutait ce serait sûrement plus
simple là notre émission les finitions
que nous a permis de faire d'ailleurs
c'est même pas la nôtre mais ça nous est
permis de faire et c'est incroyable
c'est déjà énorme mais j'espère que il y
a des gens peut-être j'ai peut-être
beaucoup d'espoir mais genre du
gouvernement ou peut-être qu'ils sont
liés qui peuvent nous entendre se dire
que peut-être qu'on a réfléchi à nos
sujets peut-être qu'on pense vraiment
ces choses là peut-être qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'appui parce que en tant que
jeune on n'a pas vraiment d'appui et en
plus on nous dit pas comment on fait
pour faire bouger les choses ou quoi
faut qu'on apprenne tout seul par
exemple on a même il y a des blocus qui
ont été faits il y a des jeunes qui
étaient en manifs certes le gouvernement
a pris peur à un certain moment
mais ça les a par exemple pas empêché de
faire passer la réforme des retraites
avec le 49.3 et il savait qu'on allait
être en colère et qu'on allait vouloir
faire bouger les choses mais ils ont
quand même fait passer un truc de force
donc un moment on essaye de se faire
écouter on essaye de se faire entendre
et plus on essaye de faire écouter se
faire entendre plus il essaie de nous
tomber dessus avec des espèces de
menaces des espèces de trucs vraiment le
49-3 personnellement je l'ai pris comme
vous allez dans la rue vous voulez
manifester vous n'êtes pas content ok
bah on vous montre qu'on est plus
puissant que vous et ça c'est quelque
chose qui ne va pas pour moi c'est un
gros écart c'est c'est vraiment pas
moral ce qu'ils ont fait mais c'est de
manière générale comme ça on nous écoute
pas on pense qu'on a pas assez réfléchi
qu'on est impulsif et qu'on est égoïste
et au final on dit oui mais faudrait que
vous fassiez bouger les choses
aidez-nous merci Achille en tout cas on
voit que ça a du répondant c'est il y a
de la grande alors juste avant d'aller
vers toi lauragne il y avait aussi de la
grande dans le public je suis désolé au
Berry je vais te faire te lever mais il
y avait une petite question si tu si tu
veux bien te déplacer encore une
dernière fois et finalement je crois
qu'il y avait plus de questions
reparti sur autre chose et
finalement il y a une question
c'est pas une question mais oui en fait
c'est juste pour dire là je suis
vraiment d'accord avec Achille moi je
sais que je fais option droit par
exemple on parle beaucoup de ce qui est
tout ce qui est actualités et tout et
quand il y a eu 49-3 et tout ça enfin
bah ça nous a vraiment énervé on sentait
vraiment concerné et on n'a pas toujours
l'opportunité de le montrer et puis
enfin moi je sais que personnellement je
me dis que c'est pas la peine d'aller
exprimer enfin je dis sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple ce que je pense pour
mes combats et tout mais enfin je vais
pas les insulter des présidents genre de
choses et tout pour leur dire de se
bouger juste des fois on sent pas assez
écouté par exemple ce qui se passait aux
États-Unis et tout le droit à
l'avortement qui a été retiré de
plusieurs États en histoire en EMC en
HLP on en a parlé partout parce que ça
nous révolte quoi c'est n'importe quoi
et ça c'est vraiment un truc on n'est
pas enfin en tant que jeune c'est-à-dire
on n'est pas forcément écouté là-dessus
et puis comme on est jeune on sait pas
tout bien sûr je suis d'accord il manque
de l'expérience et tout mais ça veut pas
dire que notre avis peut pas être pris
en compte surtout que c'est notre avenir
à nous en fait
merci et bon on va revenir par ici du
coup Lauren tu voulais dire quelque
chose aussi en fait
comment
nous dit comme dirait Achille on nous
dit qu'on bouge pas assez mais en fait
j'ai l'impression qu'on ne met plus les
bâtons dans les roues qu'autre chose
plus on bouge plus on nous met les
bâtons dans les roues pour qu'on bouge
pas et qu'on reste bien notre place et
qu'on obéisse bien ce que les adultes
nous disent et tout alors que d'un côté
on nous dit bah faut changer les choses
alors que les adultes eux-mêmes la plus
la plupart de ceux qui me disent ça ne
coûte rien pour nous aider
merci Laurent je propose qu'on passe au
dernier thème Nicolas de quoi ce qu'on
va sur quoi on va conclure oui on va
conclure sur l'écologie alors c'est un
sujet qui fait beaucoup parler chez
toutes les générations mais chez les
jeunes aussi parce qu'on en voit quand
même beaucoup se manifester dans la rue
sur les problématiques envie de
l'environnementale actuelle est-ce que
vous avez quelque chose à dire à ce
sujet mais oui peut-être il est
intéressant que nous parlons de de
l'écologie car c'est un enjeu c'est
l'enjeu de notre avenir et il faudrait
se poser la question de que va que va
devenir notre planète
quelqu'un d'autre peut-être Laurane oui
pour la pour l'écologie mais les adultes
il y a 45 ans ils auraient pu déjà
commencer à bouger pour une planète ils
ont rien fait alors que et maintenant
c'est à nous dans l'urgence d'essayer de
s'améliorer face à justement un
gouvernement qui nous écoute encore une
fois pas
et du coup c'est encore un autre changer
les choses sans se faire des comme pour
la politique alors on va prendre une
toute dernière question je suis désolé
au niveau du timing on est un peu short
et après on vous demandera en quelques
phrases très courtes vos conseils pour
les adultes et puis on arrêtera là
Rachel tu voulais ajouter une dernière
chose comme disait Laurane c'est à nous
de bouger mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a pas grand monde qui bougerait
réellement personne n'est prêt à faire
de réel efforts ou à réduire leur train
de vie pour que ce sur à que ce soit sur
n'importe quoi personne n'est prêt à
avoir réellement changé ou
vraiment faire quelque chose donc certes
faut changer les choses mais il faudrait
que quelqu'un comme tout le monde se
mette un peu du sien que ce soit à
limiter un petit élément cette phrase
tout le monde le dit ça ferait bouger un
peu plus mais il faudrait que les gens
nous prennent conscience que même si
c'est pas grand chose à force ça
pourrait prendre une plus grande ampleur
qui pourrait aider
merci beaucoup Rachel bon je suis désolé
on va pas pouvoir parler plus longtemps
de ce de cette thématique mais si je
sais qu'elle vous tenait beaucoup à
coeur parce qu'on est un petit peu
pressé par le temps on va quand même
vous demander même si c'est quand même
beaucoup revenu dans l'émission quels
sont vos conseils pour à donner aux
autres générations pour que vous les
jeunes on vous entendez on vous
comprennent mieux
parce que quelqu'un veut commencer oui
alors à tous les adultes peut-être futur
parents peut-être déjà parents qui nous
écoutent peut-être juste vous avez un
nièce un neveu que sais-je
essayer d'être gentil patient et de
comprendre que les problèmes des jeunes
c'est pas juste les problèmes des jeunes
c'est des vrais problèmes éthiques qui
nous touchent qui peuvent faire qu'on va
mal par exemple le harcèlement la santé
mentale on en a parlé des choses qui
peuvent faire qu'on se sent concernés
comme la politique parce qu'on a le
droit à avoir notre avis aussi parce
qu'on est des humains et que notre avis
est aussi valide que celui de n'importe
quel adulte ou autre ado voilà donc
prenez nous en compte
on va prendre peut-être un dernier
conseil Laurane moi j'aimerais juste te
dire un truc très simple c'est juste
dans cette époque où c'est pas forcément
facile pour tout le monde j'aimerais
juste que entre générations entre les
personnes entre les entre les
différentes nations on soit juste
solidaire entre nous s'il vous plaît
peut-être un tout dernier conseil
d'avant je crois que tu voulais dire
quelque chose et puis faut que les
parents puissent plus prêter attention
ou les responsables légaux de des
personnes qui les accompagnent de se
rendre compte que c'est des vrais
problèmes on a parlé de la du
harcèlement mais aussi il faut revenir
sur le fait de scolaire il y a des
personnes qui ne se sentent pas
adéquates dans le système scolaire
actuel et ne pas les forcer à aller à
l'école si c'est quelque chose qui les
terrifie qui leur donne la boule au
ventre de bien prendre en compte savoir
qu'il y a des il y a des systèmes qui
peut être mis en place tel que le CNED
tout ça et parler avec votre enfant ne
le laissez pas tout seul et si lui ne
veut pas vous parler
c'est son choix voilà
bon bah je pense qu'on a plutôt fait le
tour en tout cas merci à tous merci de
nous avoir donné votre avis c'était
vraiment très intéressant merci aussi à
vos professeurs qui ont travaillé avec
vous Madame bourse et Monsieur Thévenin
pour leur investissement et puis merci
aussi dans le chat d'avoir réagi aussi
rapidement je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivis puis bah je pense qu'on
peut leur dire à plus tard on peut leur
dire merci pour tout ce qu'ils ont fait
merci à vous aussi
merci
[Applaudissements]